WELL. GOOD AFTERNOON, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN. WE WELCOME YOU TO
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE. OUR JUNE
5TH EDITION. I DON'T KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED TO THE YEAR, BUT WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT EACH OF YOU WOULD
BE HERE WITH ALL OF US TODAY. I
WOULD LIKE TO GO THROUGH A BIT
OF A CADENCE HERE FOR TODAY. BUT
BEFORE WE DO, LET'S GET A QUORUM
ESTABLISHED. MADAM SECRETARY,
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL?
MAGUIRE. HERE, MAGUIRE. HERE.
GROVE. HERE GROVE! HERE. EGGMAN!
HERE! EGGMAN! HERE! JONES I'M
HERE! JONES! HERE! LAIRD. HERE.
LAIRD. HERE! QUORUM QUORUM HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED. SO WHAT WE'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO DO IS TAKE
CARE OF SOME OF OUR MORE
ADMINISTRATIVE ITEMS. FIRST,
WITH RESPECT TO THE APPOINTEES
WHO ARE HERE TODAY, WE ARE
GRATEFUL, THESE ARE SOME OF THE
MORE, MUNDANE HOUSEKEEPING
ITEMS. WE'LL TAKE CARE OF THOSE.
TAKE 5 TO 7 MINUTES, AND THEN
WE'LL COME BACK AND START THE
PRESENTATIONS FOR TODAY. SO,
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, COMMITTEE,
WHAT WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO DO
IS START ON ITEM NUMBER TWO,
ITEM NUMBER TWO ON OUR AGENDA.
THAT'S GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES NOT
REQUIRE TO APPEAR. WE'D LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO TAKE EACH OF THESE
ITEMS UP AS ONE MOTION. IS THERE
A MOTION TO APPROVE ITEMS 2D
THROUGH J 2D THROUGH J. SO WE
HAVE A MOTION BY MADAM VICE
CHAIR. MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL? MAGUIRE.
AYE. MAGUIRE. AYE. GROVE AYE.
GROVE. AYE. EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE.
JONES A. JONES. AYE. LAIRD. AYE.
LAIRD. AYE. 5 TO 0. THERE'S A50
VOTE. THAT MOTION PASSES. WE'RE
NOW GOING TO BE MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER THREE WITHIN OUR
AGENDA. THIS IS FOCUSED ON BILL
REFERRALS. IS THERE A MOTION TO
BE ABLE TO ADVANCE ITEM NUMBER
THREE REFERENCE OF BILLS TO
COMMITTEES. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MADAM VICE CHAIR. MADAM
SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL? MAGUIRE. AYE. MAGUIRE.
AYE. GROVE. GROVE. AYE. EGGMAN.
EGGMAN. AYE. JONES JONES. AYE.
LAIRD. AYE. LAIRD. AYE. 5 TO 0.
THAT'S A50 VOTE. THAT MOTION
PASSES. IT IS, LEADER JONES
FAVORITE RULE. SENATE RULE 26,
AM I RIGHT? YOU I THINK SOME
PREFERENCE. YEAH, BUT FOLLOWED
BY 27. EXACTLY YES. ALL RIGHT.
20 WAY TIE FOR HIS FAVORITE
RULE. HEY THERE WE GO, THIS IS,
IN REGARDS TO SENATE RULE 26, TO
CHANGE THE AUTHORSHIP OF BILLS.
BY NOW, CONGRESSMAN VINCE FONG,
THAT WILL THEN BE TAKEN ON BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY. ITEMS
FOUR THROUGH SIX. WE HAVE
CLEARANCE ON BOTH HOUSE
LEADERSHIP TO BE ABLE TO PUT
THESE ONTO THE AGENDA. IS THERE
A MOTION TO BE ABLE TO APPROVE
SENATE RULE 26 TO MAKE A
CORRECTION? YES. I'M SO SORRY,
IT IS NOT JUST ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY. THERE ARE OTHER AUTHORS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. SORRY. YEAH.
NO. YOU'RE GOOD. THANK YOU FOR
THE CORRECTION. PLEASE. SO
MOVED. ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MADAM VICE CHAIR. IS
THERE A, PLEASE, MADAM
SECRETARY, IF YOU COULD PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MAGUIRE. AYE.
MAGUIRE AYE. GROVE. GROVE. AYE.
EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE. JONES.
JONES. AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE 5 TO 0. THAT'S A50 VOTE.
THAT MOTION PASSES. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE
MOVING ON TO FLOOR
ACKNOWLEDGMENTS. WE'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE THIS UP ALL
TOGETHER. IS THERE A MOTION TO
BE ABLE TO APPROVE ITEMS SEVEN
THROUGH TEN? ITEM SEVEN THROUGH
TEN. WE HAVE A MOTION BY MADAM
VICE CHAIR. MADAM SECRETARY, CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL?
MAGUIRE AYE. MAGUIRE. AYE.
GROVE. GROVE. AYE. EGGMAN
EGGMAN. AYE. JONES A JONES. AYE.
LAIRD A LAIRD. AYE. 5 TO 0. THAT
IS A50 VOTE. THAT MOTION PASSES.
ALL RIGHT, LOOK AT THAT. WE GOT
OUR HOUSEKEEPING OUT OF THE WAY.
THE ADMINISTRATIVE DUTY IS DONE.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE MOVING ON
TO THE GOVERNOR. APPOINTEES
REQUIRED TO APPEAR. PORTION OF
TODAY'S AGENDA. WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH MISS LIPA. IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD. WE'LL
GIVE YOU A 30S TO BE ABLE TO
COME FORWARD, AND WE'LL BE RIGHT
BACK WITH THE COMMITTEE. MISS
LIPA IS HERE. GOING FOR THE
STATE PUBLIC DEFENDER UNDER THE
OFFICE OF THE STATE PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE. WE WELCOME
YOU AND EXCITED THAT YOU'RE HERE
TODAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME, AND PUBLIC DEFENDER,
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO IS WE'RE
GOING TO PROVIDE 1 TO 2 MINUTES
OF OPENING TESTIMONY AT THAT
TIME. WE HAVE YOU WELCOME ANY
FAMILY MEMBERS OR FRIENDS THAT
ARE HERE, WATCHING IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND OR WATCHING AT
HOME AFTER YOU'RE DONE WITH YOUR
OPENING STATEMENT, WE'RE GOING
TO OPEN IT UP FOR QUESTIONS,
CONVERSATION, DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE FROM THE COMMITTEE. THEN
WE'LL OPEN IT UP FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. WE ARE SO GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR TIME, YOUR EFFORT AND
ENERGY ON BEHALF OF THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND THANK YOU
FOR CONSIDERING MY NOMINATION
TODAY. I ALSO WANT TO THANK YOUR
STAFF FOR THE THOUGHT AND TIME
THEY PUT INTO THIS PROCESS. AND
THE GOVERNOR AND HIS STAFF AS
WELL. I WANT TO THANK MY
PARENTS, HOLLY AND JACOB, WHO
ARE HERE TODAY, AND MY DAUGHTER,
WHO IS HERE, I THINK SHE SHOULD
BE THANKING ME BECAUSE IT'S A
SCHOOL DAY. BUT I HAD MY SON WHO
IS AT HOME, I'M SURE, POUTING, I
ALSO, I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT,
THIS MOMENT TO THANK THE PEOPLE
WHO WORK AT THE OFFICE OF THE
STATE PUBLIC DEFENDER, THE
PUBLIC DEFENDERS AT OSPD STAND
BY PEOPLE AND REPRESENT THEM
UNDER SOME OF THE MOST TRYING
CIRCUMSTANCES AND IN THE MOST
COMPLEX CASES. AND THEY DO SO
WITH REALLY TREMENDOUS EMPATHY,
ZEALOUSNESS AND LEGAL SKILL. AND
IN DOING THAT WORK, THEY, YOU
KNOW, NOT ONLY PROVIDE EXCELLENT
REPRESENTATION FOR OUR CLIENTS,
BUT ALSO ENSURE THAT ALL OF OUR
LEGAL RIGHTS REMAIN STRONG. AND
TO OUR PROFESSIONAL STAFF,
REALLY, THEIR COMMITMENT TO
THEIR TO THEIR COLLEAGUES, TO
OUR MISSION AND THEIR WORK IS
UNMATCHED. I'M INCREDIBLY,
INCREDIBLY HONORED TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK SIDE ALONG
ALONGSIDE ALL OF THEM IN DOING
OUR IMPORTANT AND ESSENTIAL WORK
AT THE OFFICE OF THE STATE
PUBLIC DEFENDER, AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO ANSWERING ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE WANT TO
WELCOME YOUR PARENTS, POLLY AND
JACOB. WELCOME. IT IS SO NICE TO
SEE YOU AS WELL. AND YOU'RE
GOING TO RUB IT IN WITH YOUR
BROTHER WHEN YOU GET HOME, SO I
LIKE IT. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ATTENDING. LET'S OPEN IT UP WITH
SENATOR LAIRD, PLEASE. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND I JUST HAVE
TO MENTION THAT I'M A
SIMULTANEOUS COMMITTEE HEARING
GOING ON, AND I'M GOING TO HAVE
TO LEAVE TO VOTE SOMETIME. AND
IT'S NOT PERSONAL. SO SO THAT'S
WHY I THOUGHT I WOULD START IN
CASE I GET THE CALL, I'M SORRY
WE DIDN'T HAVE A CHANCE TO MEET.
BUT IN READING THE INFORMATION,
THERE'S THIS FASCINATING HISTORY
OF YOUR OFFICE OF WHEN IT
STARTED. AND BASICALLY AT FIRST,
THERE WERE ALL THESE CERTAIN
KIND OF CASES US. AND THEN IN
THE 1990S, IT IT MOVED TO,
HEAVILY DEATH PENALTY CASES. AND
THEN, IT'S CHANGED A LITTLE AND
SORT OF HOW THAT'S MOVED AHEAD.
TALK ABOUT JUST SORT OF THE
HISTORY OF WHAT THE FOCUS HAS
BEEN OF YOUR OFFICE AND WHERE IT
PUTS YOU RIGHT NOW IN SORT OF
WHAT YOUR CHIEF FOCUS IS. SURE
WELL, IN SOME WAYS, YOU'VE,
YOU'VE YOU LAID OUT THE HISTORY
OSPD STARTED OBVIOUSLY. WELL
BEFORE MY TIME AS AN OFFICE.
THAT WAS PROVIDING, APPELLATE
REPRESENTATION, THAT IS REQUIRED
FOR THE STATE TO, TO ROUTE, TO
PROVIDE IN A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT HIGH LEVEL CASES. IT
DID MOVE INTO, PROVIDING DEATH
PENALTY REPRESENTATION ON DIRECT
APPEAL, WHEN THE NUMBER OF THOSE
CASES SORT OF EXCEEDED, THE
ABILITY FOR THE OFFICE TO TAKE
ON THOSE CASES AND OTHER CASES,
IN RECENT YEARS, WE HAVE
EXPANDED OUR THE LEGISLATURE HAS
EXPANDED OUR MANDATE AND WE NOW,
WHILE WE STILL PRIORITIZE
REPRESENTING CLIENTS ON DIRECT
APPEAL IN DEATH PENALTY CASES,
THAT IS THE BIGGEST PRIORITY OF
OUR OFFICE, WE ALSO TAKE ON THE
WORK OF ENSURING THAT THE
GENERAL PUBLIC DEFENSE SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA IS, BEING PROVIDED
WITH TRAINING AND RESOURCES.
REYES, ACROSS THE STATE, WE,
SPEND A PARTICULAR FOCUS ON, ON
SMALLER AND RURAL COUNTIES WHO,
BENEFIT FROM PROFESSIONAL
SUPPORT. AND SO IT'S BECOME, IN
SOME WAYS, A SOMEWHAT, MORE
HOLISTIC OFFICE. ALTHOUGH I WILL
SAY THAT OUR DIRECT
REPRESENTATION MAINTAINS FOCUSED
ON ON DEATH PENALTY APPEALS. AND
WHEN, PROPOSITION 66 PASSED, IT
WAS SUPPOSED TO STREAMLINE IN
SOME WAYS, THE DEATH PENALTY
CASES. HOW DO YOU BELIEVE THAT'S
WORKED OUT? HAVE YOU SEEN THAT
IN THE WORK OF YOUR OFFICE? SO,
I CANNOT SPEAK TO THE SORT OF
LONG STANDING HISTORY I HAVE
BEEN WITH THE OFFICE FOR THREE
YEARS, AND IN THIS ROLE FOR FOUR
MONTHS. FIVE MONTHS NOW, BUT I
WILL SAY THAT THERE HAS BEEN A
REDUCTION IN THE BACKLOG OF
CASES THAT ARE AWAITING, DIRECT
APPEAL. COUNSEL. BUT THERE
REMAIN DELAYS WITHIN THE DEATH
PENALTY SYSTEM THAT, REMAIN
TODAY. OKAY. AND THEN MAYBE A
LAST QUESTION. WHAT ARE YOUR
GOALS FOR THE OFFICE? WHAT DO
YOU THINK COMING IN, AND HOW DO
YOU WANT TO TAKE IT TO WHATEVER
THE NEXT LEVEL IS? YEAH. SO MY
GOAL FIRST AND FOREMOST IS TO
PROVIDE, AN EXCELLENT
REPRESENTATION TO OUR CLIENTS. I
BELIEVE THAT IS OUR FIRST AND
FOREMOST PRIORITY AND THAT
CALIFORNIA CAN BE, A REAL LEADER
IN DEMONSTRATING WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE, IN A, IN A PUBLIC DEFENDER
OFFICE, BESIDE THAT, I HAVE THE
GOAL OF ENSURING A HEALTHY AND
DIVERSE WORKPLACE AND IN
PROVIDING, RESOURCES AND
INFORMATION TO ALL CALIFORNIANS
ABOUT HOW THE PUBLIC DEFENDER
SYSTEMS WORK IN CALIFORNIA AND
HOW THE LEGAL PROCESS WORKS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND, ENSURING THAT,
YOU KNOW, WE CAN WE DO IT AS
WELL AS WE CAN. OKAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SENATOR, PLEASE. MADAM
VICE-CHAIR. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. THANK YOU. AND I
APOLOGIZE THAT I DIDN'T GET A
CHANCE TO MEET WITH YOU EITHER.
WE'VE GOT MULTIPLE COMMITTEES
AND THAT'S NO EXCUSE. AND THEN A
NONPROFIT OF THE YEAR. SO I DO
APOLOGIZE, I READ ALL YOUR
DOCUMENTS. YOU ARE VERY HIGHLY
QUALIFIED. I WILL TELL YOU THAT.
BUT I DO HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS REGARDING, YOUR
POSITION ON THE DEATH PENALTY. I
KNOW THAT YOUR OFFICE EARLIER
THIS YEAR JOINED A, FILED A WRIT
OF PETITION WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT ARGUING THAT THE
STATE'S CAPITAL PUNISHMENT
SYSTEM IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL, THE
SUPREME COURT HAS DEEMED IT
CONSTITUTIONAL. THEY SAID IT WAS
AN UNCONSTITUTIONAL. AND, THEY
THEY DO HAVE A, WHEN THEY DID
THIS STATEMENT, ON THE EIGHTH
AMENDMENT, THE CONSTITUTION
PROVIDES OR, EXCUSE ME, FORBIDS
CRUEL AND UNUSUAL PUNISHMENT,
BUT IT DOES NOT CATEGORIZE OR
CATEGORICALLY PROHIBIT THE DEATH
PENALTY. I REALIZE THAT THIS WAS
ALL DONE BEFORE YOU ARE BEING
APPOINTED TO THIS POSITION, BUT
I, HOWEVER, HAVE UNDERSTAND
BASED ON WHAT I READ THAT AND
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG, WILL
YOU CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THAT
EFFORT, EVEN SO, IN 2016,
CALIFORNIANS REJECTED REPEALING,
THE DEATH PENALTY, CASE. SO
AGAINST THE WILL OF THE PEOPLE
AS THE POSITION YOU'RE BEING
APPOINTED TO, DO YOU STILL HOLD
FIRM THAT THE DECISION THAT YOU
HAVE MADE TO JOIN THAT SUPREME
COURT DECISION? THÀNH. YES. SO
IN TERMS OF WHAT THE, THE
ORIGINAL WRIT ALLEGED, IT IS
THAT THE DEATH PENALTY AS
APPLIED AS CURRENTLY APPLIED IN
CALIFORNIA, IS A VIOLATION OF
THE STATE EQUAL PROTECTION
CLAUSE. SO NOT THE DEATH PENALTY
, WRIT LARGE AS A PUNISHMENT.
BUT IN TERMS OF HOW IT IS LAID
OUT IN CALIFORNIA AND HOW IT
PLAYS OUT IN CALIFORNIA AT IN
THE MOMENT THAT, THAT IS AN
IMPORTANT DISTINCTION PRECISELY.
VÆ, FOR THE REASON YOU RAISED,
WHICH IS BOTH THE FEDERAL COURT
AND THE PROPOSITION, I WILL,
NOTE THAT THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION OBVIOUSLY CARRIES
ITS OWN WEIGHT AND FORCE AND IS
INTERPRETED SEPARATELY BY THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT, AND
THAT IS THEIR RESPONSIBILITY TO
ASSESS IT, IN TERMS OF, IN TERMS
OF OUR CONSTITUTION, SO I DO
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THAT, THAT,
THAT CASE, WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION
TO OUR CLIENTS TO, BRING FORWARD
ALL POTENTIAL AVENUES TO RESOLVE
THEIR CLAIMS. THANK YOU. AND THE
SECOND QUESTION I HAVE IS SAME
SUBJECT LINE, IF THAT IS
SUPPORTED AND IT DOES OVERTURN
ON THE DEATH PENALTY PER SE, I
KNOW IT'S ON A, I BELIEVE, AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER NOW, BUT IF IT
DOES, WHAT HAPPENS TO THOSE
PEOPLE THAT ARE ON DEATH ROW,
LIKE DO THEY STAY IN PRISON OR
IS DO THEY HAVE ELIGIBILITY FOR
RELEASE? OR WHAT HAPPENS TO
THOSE INDIVIDUALS? SO THAT WOULD
NOT BE, OF COURSE, OUR DECISION
TO MAKE, SO AGAIN, THE IF, IF IT
THAT IS SORT OF I THINK IN A
WORLD WHERE, MANY DIFFERENT
THINGS COULD HAPPEN, IT WOULD BE
AGAIN, IT'S AN AS APPLIED
CHALLENGE. SO IT WAS POSSIBLE
THAT THE STATE COULD COME AND
SORT OF CORRECT THE ASPECTS OF
IT THAT WERE FOUND TO BE FLAWED.
IF THAT WAS THE CASE, AND THEN,
THERE WOULD HAVE TO BE SORT OF
JUDICIAL DETERMINATIONS ABOUT
ABOUT WHAT COMES NEXT. BUT IT'S,
NOT A SITUATION WHERE, FOLKS ARE
JUST RELEASED AND OUR TAXPAYER
DOLLARS USED FOR THIS WRIT AND
FOR THE RESOURCES TO, TO, TO
SUPPORT THIS, OR IS THAT DONE
INDIVIDUALLY BY INDIVIDUALS? MY
STAFF IS PAID THROUGH TAX
DOLLARS, THROUGH TAXPAYER
DOLLARS, JOINED ON TO THIS AS
TAXPAYER EXPENSE, EVEN THOUGH
THE TAXPAYER IS REJECTED. THE
REPEAL WE REPRESENT, FOLKS ON
WHO ARE SENTENCED TO DEATH. AND
SO THAT IS OUR TAXPAYER FUNDED
ROLE. I JUST YEAH, JUST WANT TO
MAKE THAT THE OTHER QUESTION. I
HAVE TOTALLY SEPARATE SUBJECT
MATTER. I REPRESENT A LOT OF
RURAL COMMUNITIES, AS DOES THE
PRO TEM AND, YOU'VE MADE A
STATEMENT THAT SOMETIMES THERE'S
NOT EVEN A DEDICATED PUBLIC
DEFENDER IN SOME OF THOSE RURAL
COMMUNITIES, WHAT RESOURCES OR
IDEAS HAVE YOU TAKING THIS ROLE?
DO YOU HAVE? BECAUSE, SOME OF
OUR RURAL COMMUNITIES IN THE
STATE, THEY DESERVE A PUBLIC
DEFENDER AS WELL. SO JUST WHAT'S
YOUR THOUGHT PROCESS ON MAKING
SURE AT LEAST THAT, IN EVERY
COUNTY THERE ARE PUBLIC
DEFENDERS THAT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO HELP, PROTECT THOSE
THAT ARE IN THE SITUATION THAT
THEY FIND THEMSELVES IN. THANK
YOU FOR THIS QUESTION. IT IS
SUCH AN IMPORTANT ISSUE, IT IS
TRUE THAT IN CALIFORNIA, EACH
COUNTY CAN DESIGN ITS OWN
SYSTEM, AND MANY SMALL AND RURAL
COUNTIES DO NOT HAVE PUBLIC
DEFENDER SYSTEMS, WE HAVE TAKEN
A LOOK AT WHAT SOME OTHER STATES
DO THAT ALSO HAVE A VARIETY OF
SMALL AND RURAL COUNTIES. I WILL
NOTE THAT, FOR EXAMPLE, IN IN
TEXAS, MANY SMALL AND RURAL
COUNTIES, JOINED TOGETHER TO
HAVE A MULTI-JURISDICTIONAL
COUNTY, SMALL AND RURAL COUNTIES
IN CALIFORNIA DO THAT ALREADY.
AND FOR A NUMBER OF OTHER
MATTERS, OFTEN FOR JUVENILE HALL
, SOMETIMES FOR, VARIOUS OTHER
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT THEY HAVE.
SO THAT IS CERTAINLY ONE
OPPORTUNITY. WE ALSO RECOGNIZE
THAT SOME COUNTIES SIMPLY DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH LAWYERS. THERE'S
SIMPLY A DEARTH OF LAWYERS. SO
THINKING ABOUT PIPELINE INTO
BRINGING ATTORNEYS AND MAKING IT
REALISTIC FOR THEM TO LIVE IN
SMALL AND RURAL COUNTIES, THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
ANSWERING MY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH, MADAM
VICE CHAIR. LET'S GO TO SENATOR
EGGMAN, PLEASE. THANK YOU. AND
MY APOLOGIES. ALSO, WE DIDN'T
GET A CHANCE TO MEET. AND THANK
YOU FOR BRAVING THE HEAT ON YOUR
WAY OUT WITH YOUR. YOUR WHOLE
FAMILY'S DEHYDRATED, MY
QUESTIONS ARE KIND OF ON A
DIFFERENT LINE. I'VE DONE A LOT
OF WORK IN THE MENTAL HEALTH
SPACE, AND ONE OF THE AREAS OR
PROGRAMS I WAS PART OF HELPING
DEVELOP WAS THE CARE COURT. THE
CARE SYSTEM. AND WE'VE HEARD
FROM SOME CITIES THAT THEY'RE
HAVING A LOT OF TROUBLE WORKING
WITH THE PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE, SO I GUESS I WONDERED IF
YOU COULD TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHAT REPRESENTATION LOOKS
LIKE, BECAUSE YOU SAID, RIGHT,
EVERYONE IS ENTITLED TO
REPRESENTATION, BUT I THINK SOME
OF THE CONCERNS AND I AND I, AND
I WANT TO FIND A WAY TO WORK ON
IT, THAT GETTING SOMEBODY INTO
TREATMENT RIGHT TO ME IS GOOD
REPRESENTATION THAT THEY CAN
BEGIN TO GET HELP SO THEY DON'T
END UP IN THE CRIMINAL SYSTEM.
AND SINCE IT'S A CIVIL SYSTEM,
IT'S DIFFERENT. SO DO YOU DOES
YOUR OFFICE HAVE ANY,
AUTHORIZATION OR OVERSIGHT OF
PUBLIC DEFENSE AS IT RELATES IN
CIVIL COURTS LIKE, YOU KNOW, IN
COMMUNITY COURTS TO TRY TO GET
PEOPLE HELP VERSUS TRYING TO
KEEP THEM FROM GETTING HELP AND
THEN OFTENTIMES REOFFEND. AND,
SO TO ANSWER THE SECOND
QUESTION, WE DON'T HAVE ANY
AUTHORITY OVER THESE LOCAL
OFFICES, IT IS A COMPLICATED
ISSUE, AS YOU NOTE. SERVICES
PROVIDED THROUGH THE LEGAL
SYSTEM ARE ALWAYS COMPLICATED IN
THAT WAY. AND THE ROLE OF A
PUBLIC DEFENDER IS TO REPRESENT
THEIR CLIENT, SO THIS IS AN
ONGOING ISSUE. I WILL NOTE THAT
CARE COURT, AS YOU KNOW, HAS IS
VERY, VERY NEW. IT WAS JUST
ROLLED OUT IN THE PILOT
COUNTIES. WE ARE AWARE OF IT.
WE'VE DONE A NUMBER OF TRAININGS
ON IT, BUT IT'S GOING TO HAVE TO
SORT OF GROW AND PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE POSSIBILITIES ARE AND HOW TO
BEST MEET THEIR CLIENT'S NEEDS
AND THEIR COMMUNITY'S NEEDS, YOU
HAVE IDEAS ABOUT IMPLEMENTATION.
IDEAS? YES BUT I AM NOT A POLICY
MAKER FOR, AND I THINK MUCH OF
THIS HAS TO DO. AND I WILL ALSO
SAY THAT EVERY COUNTY DOES IT
DIFFERENTLY. THAT IS PRIMARILY
THE ISSUE IS THAT EVERY COUNTY
DOES IT DIFFERENTLY. AND TO
SPEAK IN GENERALITIES IS JUST
NOT HELPFUL WHEN YOU KNOW HOW
COUNTIES INTERACT. WHO IS DOING
THE WORK IN A PARTICULAR COUNTY
IS VERY LOCAL, BUT I, I DO THINK
THAT THE MORE, SERVICES ARE
PROVIDED IN A NON-COERCIVE
SETTING AND COOPERATIVELY AND IN
A WAY THAT, MEETS PEOPLE'S NEEDS
AND WHERE THEY ARE, THE BETTER
IT IS FOR EVERYBODY. WE ALL MAKE
THAT SAME ARGUMENT. ALL WE CAN
DO IS TRY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. ALL RIGHT. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME FROM THE COMMITTEE. ALL
RIGHT. HEARING SEEING NONE. WHAT
WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO DO IS
OPEN IT UP. PUBLIC COMMENT FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
MADAM PUBLIC DEFENDER, IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD AT
THIS TIME, WE'RE GOING TO ASK
FOLKS TO BE ABLE TO COME FORWARD
TO THE PODIUM, PROVIDE YOUR
FIRST AND LAST NAME, AND IF
YOU'RE WITH AN ORGANIZATION, IF
YOU COULD PLEASE PROVIDE THE
NAME OF THE ORGANIZATION AS
WELL. WE'RE GOING TO OPEN IT UP
FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT. THOSE IN
SUPPORT. PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
HEARING AND SEEING NO ONE RISE.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO SEEK THOSE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD TO THE
PODIUM AT THIS TIME. I REALLY
HOPE MY DAD'S NOT STANDING, IS
HE? THERE WE GO. EXACTLY. I I
LIKE IT. WE'RE GONNA DO A LAST
CALL FOR OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT?
WE'RE GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE TO BE ABLE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY LAST MINUTE
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE FROM THE
MEMBERS HEARING. SEEING NONE. IS
THERE A MOTION TO, FOR APPROVAL?
SO MOVED. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR EGGMAN. MADAM SECRETARY,
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL?
MCGUIRE. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
GROVE. GROVE. AYE. EGGMAN
EGGMAN. AYE. JONES. JONES. NOT
VOTING. LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE. 4 TO
0. THAT IS A FOUR ZERO VOTE.
CONGRATULATIONS. NEXT UP IS THE
SENATE FLOOR. WE'RE GRATEFUL.
AND AGAIN, PLEASE. IS SO
WONDERFUL TO HAVE YOUR FAMILY
HERE WITH US TODAY. THEY MUST BE
SO INCREDIBLY PROUD. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
32ND BREAK, ALLOW MADAM PUBLIC
DEFENDER AND THE FAMILY TO BE
ABLE TO EXIT THE CHAMBERS, AND
THEN WE'LL BRING IT BACK. IN THE
MEANTIME, WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
MR. DIRECTOR, PLEASE COME ON UP,
WE'RE GOING TO BE TALKING WITH
JARED PATTON IN 30S, GOING UP
FOR CONFIRMATION AND DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS. 30S, PLEASE.
ALL RIGHT. WE DIRECTOR, YOU MAY
SEE MEMBERS COMING IN AND OUT IT
IS. TIS THE SEASON, RIGHT, OF
MULTIPLE COMMITTEES, AND WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR PATIENCE WITH
THAT. MR. DIRECTOR, IT'S GOOD TO
SEE YOU AGAIN. WELCOME WE ALSO
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE YOU HAVE A
HECK OF A CHEERING SECTION WITH
YOU HERE TODAY, WHICH WE ALWAYS
LOVE, YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE 1 OR
2 MINUTES TO PROVIDE OPENING
TESTIMONY. AND THE 1 TO 2
MINUTES WE ARE GOING TO WELCOME
ANY REMARKS AND ANY
ACKNOWLEDGMENT, ANY
ACKNOWLEDGMENTS THAT YOU MAY
HAVE OF INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE HERE
WITH YOU TODAY, WE'RE GOING TO
BE KEEPING TIME, I'LL GIVE YOU A
HEADS UP WHEN YOU GET TO ABOUT
30S IN FRONT OF TWO MINUTES.
OKAY, AND WE'RE GRATEFUL. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE, SIR.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR MCGUIRE.
VICE CHAIR GROVE LEFT, BUT WE'LL
BE BACK AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, MY NAME IS JARED JP
PATTON. AND I'M HONORED AND
GRATEFUL TO BE APPOINTED BY
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM TO SERVE
AS THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS.
MY PARENTS CAREERS WERE
DEDICATED TO CALIFORNIA STATE
SERVICE AND WHILE THEY ARE NO
LONGER WITH ME, I WOULD LIKE TO
THINK THEY ARE QUITE PROUD OF
THIS DAY AT HOME. MY PARTNER
SILAS IS ROOTING FOR ME ONLINE.
THANK YOU AND I LOVE YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND WATCHING FROM
THEIR OFFICES IS AN INCREDIBLE
C.C.C. TEAM AND THE LEADERSHIP
OF CNRA. I'M HUMBLED BY THE
PRESENCE OF FRIENDS, MENTORS,
AND COLLABORATORS, INCLUDING MY
PREDECESSOR, BRUCE SAITO, SENIOR
DEPUTY DIRECTOR LARRY NOTICE,
THE LEADERS OF THE C.C.C.
FOUNDATION, THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS, AS THE
SACRAMENTO LOCAL CORPS, THE
NORTH BAY CONSERVATION CORPS,
AND CIVIC CORPS OF OAKLAND
HONORABLE MEMBERS. MY CAREER HAS
BEEN DEDICATED TO PUBLIC SERVICE
, PARTICULARLY IN THE GOOD WORK
OF ENGAGING YOUNG ADULTS IN
OUTDOOR EDUCATION, RECREATION,
CONSERVATION, AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. MY PRIMARY FOCUS IS
TO FULFILL OUR MANDATE TO
PROVIDE CORPS MEMBERS WITH
EMPLOYMENT PATHWAYS THROUGH
ACADEMIC AND JOB SKILLS TRAINING
. FINALLY, AS REPRESENTED BY
THIS BLUE CORPS MEMBER HAT, I
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION FOR ALL
CORPS MEMBERS SERVING CALIFORNIA
AND I PUBLICLY REAFFIRM MY
COMMITMENT TO THEIR SUCCESS.
TODAY IS THE FIRST DAY ON THE
JOB FOR CORPS MEMBER ALEX
MORENO, WHO IS EXCHANGING HIS
BLUE C.C.C. HAT FOR HIS CALFIRE
HAT WITH A TEHAMA GLENN UNIT.
HIS STORY IN THE 1600 OTHER
CORPS MEMBER STORIES INSPIRED ME
TO LEAD THE C.C.C. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR KIND CONSIDERATION AND FOR
THE TIME YOU AND YOUR STAFF HAVE
MADE FOR ME IN THIS PROCESS, AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO OUR
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MR. DIRECTOR. VERY GRATEFUL THAT
YOU'RE HERE. LET'S START OUT
WITH SENATOR LAIRD. GREAT. THANK
YOU. BECAUSE THEY'RE ON THE
FOURTH BILL AND LABOR. AND THIS
WAS A VERY IMPORTANT
CONFIRMATION TO ME, I REALLY
APPRECIATE IT, WE HAVE HAD
MULTIPLE MEETINGS, EVEN
UNRELATED TO THIS. AND YOUR. WE
TALKED ABOUT SO MUCH. IT'S HARD
TO FOCUS AND THE FACT THAT YOUR
PREDECESSOR IS HERE. HE WAS
OUTSTANDING. AND THE FACT THAT
HE CAME FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
FOR THIS IS A TRIBUTE TO YOU,
ONE THING TO TALK ABOUT IS AND
FIRST, AT SOME POINT, I'LL
EXPLAIN TO PEOPLE THE HIERARCHY
OF HATS AND WHAT A BLUE HAT
MEANS. BUT, THERE HAS BEEN A
CHANGE WITH THE DECENTRALIZATION
OF PRISONS, A LOT OF THE
PRISONERS GO TO THE SHERIFFS AND
THEY ARE LESS AVAILABLE FOR THE
PRISON FIRE CORPS. AND IT HAS
PUT A BIGGER RESPONSIBILITY ON
THE CONSERVATION CORPS. AND I
THINK THE OUR CONVERSATION SAID
IT IS UP TO 30% OF THE CORPS
MEMBERS ARE RELATED TO
FIREFIGHTING. HOW HAVE YOU
HANDLED THAT TREND? DO YOU SEE
IT A TREND STILL CONTINUING? AND
IT'S REALLY THRILLING THAT YOU
USED THE EXAMPLE OF SOMEBODY
THAT THAT IS GOING INTO THE FIRE
SERVICE FROM THE CORPS. HOW IS
THAT FITTING WITH THE CORPS AT
THIS TIME? IT IS THRILLING, AND
IT'S A IT'S AN AREA OF GROWTH
FOR THE CORPS. WE'VE GONE
THROUGH SOME INCREDIBLE GROWTH
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS.
YOU ARE CORRECT. ABOUT 30% OF
OUR CREWS ARE DEDICATED TO
FIGHTING FIRES. WHERE THEY'RE
NOT FIGHTING FIRES, THEY'RE
DOING IMPORTANT FUELS, WORK, SO
WE'VE WELCOMED THIS. WE PREPARED
FOR THIS. I THINK THERE IS
ALWAYS IS A CASE TO BE MADE, TO
CONTINUE TO GROW IN THIS SPACE.
BUT WE'VE HIT THIS GREAT POINT
WHERE WE'RE SEEING SO MANY YOUNG
CORPS MEMBERS GET PICKED UP FOR
CAL FIRE POSITIONS. I THINK
ABOUT 513 OR SO TO DATE, AROUND
100 THIS YEAR ALREADY, SO I'M
VERY PROUD OF THE 30 CAL FIRE
CREWS THAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE AT
THE C.C.C. I DO THINK WITH THE
ACCELERATING CLIMATE CRISIS THAT
THIS IS IT'S VITAL, I'M PROUD
THAT SOME OF OUR CREWS THAT ARE
PERMANENT OR EXCUSE ME, WERE
TEMPORARY, ARE NOW PERMANENT UP
IN FORTUNA AND CHICO. THAT'S A
GOOD SIGN TO ME. THAT IS A
STRONG TESTAMENT OF THE
DIRECTION THAT WE'RE HEADING.
SO, DO WE WANT TO GROW AND
CONTINUE? ABSOLUTELY. I WANT FAR
MORE CÁC CENTERS OUT THERE. AND
YET, THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET WHILE SAYING, OH, WE'LL
JUST LET THE ONE TIME FUNDS
EXPIRE AS IF THAT IS SIGNIFICANT
IN THE UNIVERSE. IT CUTS, THE
CORPS SIGNIFICANTLY DOWN TO WHAT
THE ONGOING BASELINE IS. AND SO
WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO DO THIS
AND GOD HELP US, WE'VE BEEN
LUCKY THE LAST TWO YEARS, WE'RE
JUST FALLING INTO THE OCEAN. WE
HAVEN'T GONE BACK TO FIRE. BUT
WHEN WE GO BACK TO FIRES, IS
THIS GOING TO BE ENOUGH
RESOURCES FOR YOU TO HAVE CORPS
MEMBERS SUPPLEMENT CAL FIRE IN
THAT FIRE FIGHTING? WE'RE GOING
TO DO THE BEST THAT WE CAN WITH
THE RESOURCES THAT WE'VE GOT. 30
CREWS IS 450 CORPS MEMBERS WERE
SPREAD OUT ALL ACROSS THE STATE.
SO I FEEL, CONFIDENT AND
SUFFICIENT THAT THE CREWS THAT
WE HAVE WILL BE ABLE TO RESPOND
AND DO AND DO A GREAT JOB, WHAT
WILL COME OF THE BUDGET SEASON
WILL TELL, AND WE WILL CROSS
THAT RIVER WHEN WE GET TO IT,
BUT RIGHT NOW, I THINK WE ARE
SUFFICIENTLY STAFF AND
SUPPORTED. I WOULD EXPECT YOU,
IN THE INTEREST OF KEEPING YOUR
JOB, TO BE SUPPORTIVE. THANK
YOU. BUT I THINK IT IS WORTH
HIGHLIGHTING. I APPRECIATE THERE
IS THAT CHALLENGE, THERE THERE.
ANOTHER CHALLENGE IS, IS THAT I
THINK THE CURRENT NUMBER IS AND
I COULD BE WRONG. 82% OF THE
CORPS MEMBERS ARE MEN. YES. AND
HOW ARE YOU MOVING IN A WAY THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE A LITTLE
MORE EQUITY IN WHO'S IN THE
CORPS. I APPRECIATE THAT
QUESTION. SO ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I INTEND TO DO IN THIS ROLE
IS MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A
CORPS FOR ALL, AND THAT LOOKS
LIKE MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE AT
CLOSER PARITY. GENDER PARITY IN
THE CORPS. AND SO WE'VE GOT SOME
ROOM TO GROW IN THAT SPACE. THE
NUMBER IS CORRECT. IT'S ABOUT 80
TO 20 AT THIS POINT. AND WE'VE
DONE A COUPLE OF GREAT THINGS.
NUMBER ONE, OUR OUR LEADERSHIP
TEAM RECENTLY WENT TO A
GOVERNMENT SUMMIT ABOUT WOMEN IN
GOVERNMENT. AND FROM THAT THEY
CAME BACK REALLY ENERGIZED ABOUT
THE TRAINING AND MENTORSHIP
PROGRAMS THEY WANT TO BRING TO
THE CORPS, WE HAVE BEEN TALKING
TO OUR STAFF, OUR CORPS MEMBERS,
CBOS, OTHER THOUGHT PARTNERS
ABOUT WHAT TO DO. WE'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS. EVERYONE HERE ON
THIS, ON THIS PANEL, AND WE HAVE
SOME REALLY, REALLY GOOD IDEAS.
THEY'RE NOT FULLY BAKED, BUT
WE'RE IN THEIR EARLY STAGES. BUT
IT LOOKS LIKE THIS, FOR FOLKS
WHO ARE PROVIDING CHILD CARE OR
KIN CARE OR ELDER CARE, WHAT
COULD WE DO AS A CORPS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE FOLKS ARE
SUPPORTED WITH RESOURCES FOR
THAT CARE? AND THAT LOOKS LIKE
PARTNERING WITH MAYBE CBOS TO
SUPPORT THAT. ANOTHER THING
WE'RE THINKING OF IS, IN OUR
PROJECT PORTFOLIO, ARE THERE
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT WE CAN BE
EMPHASIZING RELATIVE TO
INTERPRETATION, EDUCATION, OR
STEM THAT MIGHT BE ATTRACTIVE TO
FOLKS, TO OUR PROGRAM, AND
FINALLY, WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT,
YOU KNOW, WE'VE GOT MY EXECUTIVE
TEAM IS COMPRISED OF OVER 50%
WOMEN, AND MANY OF THEM WERE
CORPS MEMBERS. AND SO YOU MIGHT
HEAR SOME THINGS, IN THE FUTURE
ABOUT US SHIFTING OUR SELECTION.
EXCUSE ME, THE, THE
CLASSIFICATIONS THAT WE USE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE UPWARD
MOBILITY IS MAINTAINED. WE ALSO
HAVE TARGETED RECRUITMENT. YOU
SEE A LOT OF OUR STORYTELLING ON
ALL OF OUR CHANNELS WILL BE
FOCUSED ON GETTING THE WORD OUT
TO WOMEN THAT THE CDC IS HERE,
AND THERE'S A PLACE FOR WOMEN IN
THE CDC. SO THERE'S A LOT OF
GREAT WORK AHEAD OF US. AND
THANK YOU TO, BECAUSE I KNOW WE
HAD TO DO SOME LEGISLATION THAT
MADE THE TERM'S APPLYING TO THE
CORPS MORE GENDER NEUTRAL, ONE
LAST QUESTION. AND THAT IS, IS I
REMEMBER I WAS REALLY IMPRESSED
AND WE TALKED ABOUT IT WHEN WE
MET. WE HAVE THIS PROBLEM THAT
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH, EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR VETERANS
COMING OUT OF THE MILITARY AT
THE SAME TIME, OUR VETERANS POOL
IS 82% MEN. AND SO IF YOU GIVE
VETERANS PREFERENCE, YOU'RE
JUMPING A LOT OF MEN UP IN FRONT
OF WOMEN. AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT HAS IMPRESSED ME IS YOU
HAVE VETERANS, DIFFERENT
VETERANS UNITS WHERE PEOPLE COME
OUT, THEY SERVE WITH YOU, THEY
LAND SOMEWHERE. WHEN THEY COME
OUT, THEY ARE EMPLOYABLE. I WENT
OUT TO THE BACK TRAIL CREWS WITH
SOME OF THE VETERANS CREWS. NICE
TALK ABOUT HOW MANY YOU'VE GOT
AND HOW THAT'S WORKING RIGHT
NOW, OUR VETERANS PROGRAM. THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION. SO TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS, YOU CAN BE
18 TO 25, UP TO 29 IF YOU'RE A
VETERAN. AND THERE ARE FIVE
LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
AT OUR CENTERS WHERE WE HAVE
PROGRAMS DEDICATED TO THE
SUPPORT OF VETS, I THINK
CURRENTLY WE HAVE ABOUT 50 OR SO
VETS WHO HAVE ENTERED THE
PROGRAM SINCE THE BEGINNING OF
THE YEAR, AND THAT'S A
CONSIDERABLE AND AWESOME SUM AT
OUR CENTERS IN FORTUNA,
CAMARILLO, WILLITS. EXCUSE ME.
UKIAH SOON TO BE WILLITS, DELTA
AND THOSE PADRES. WE HAVE
PROGRAMS RAIMES. WE HAVE A NOAA
FISHERIES VET PROGRAM AS WELL.
AND IT DOES EXACTLY AS YOU
MENTIONED. IT IS A LANDING
PLACE, A SECOND HOME, AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR VETERANS TO GET
NEW SKILLS, RETOOL, AND THEN GET
BACK OUT THERE INTO THE
WORKFORCE WHEN THEY'RE READY.
THAT'S GREAT. AND MENTIONING
FISHERIES PROBABLY ENDEARED
YOURSELF TO THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE. SO THANK YOU FOR
DOING THAT. THANK YOU. I COULD
GO ON BECAUSE I'M A REAL
BELIEVER IN THE CORPS AND WHAT
IT DOES. AND ONE OF THE
HIGHLIGHTS FOR ME EVERY YEAR
WHEN I WAS SECRETARY WAS 15
CORPS MEMBERS COME IN, COMING IN
AND TELLING ME THEIR LIFE STORY.
IT WAS MOVING, THANK YOU. AND IT
REALLY TURNED PEOPLE AROUND IN
REALLY POSITIVE WAYS. SO, THANK
YOU FOR BEING WILLING TO SERVE.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO VOTING FOR
YOUR CONFIRMATION. I APPRECIATE
IT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU SO MUCH TO MR. SECRETARY.
NOW, SENATOR, AS WELL. THAT'S
RIGHT. THIS HAS BEEN AN ABSOLUTE
PASSION OF SENATOR LAIRD. SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH. PLEASE.
SENATOR EGGMAN, I THOUGHT I WAS
THE BIGGEST CHAMPION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS,
BUT APPARENTLY IN LINE RIGHT
NOW. GET IN LINE BEHIND SENATOR
LAIRD, AND HE ASKED MOST OF MY
QUESTIONS. I WAS GOING TO ASK,
WE HAD A GREAT CONVERSATION. I
ENJOYED MEETING WITH YOU, AND
I'M A HUGE BELIEVER IN THE
CORPS. THE GENDER EQUITY ISSUE
IS, IS ONE THAT IS VERY MUCH OF
INTEREST TO ME, AND SO I'M, I'M
INTRIGUED BY YOUR IDEA BECAUSE I
KNOW WE'RE FOCUSED ON, ON
OUTDOORS, BUT IF, IF THERE'S
EVER THOUGHT OF PROVIDING
CERTIFICATES AND TRAINING FOR,
FOR CAREGIVING AND MAYBE EVEN
CAREGIVING OUT IN THE
ENVIRONMENT, WE KNOW THAT'S ONE
OF THE BEST THINGS FOR MENTAL
HEALTH IS THE OUTDOORS. YES AS
ANOTHER WAY TO POTENTIALLY BRING
IN WOMEN. THANK YOU. YEAH. AND
YOU REMINDED ME TOO, THAT WE'VE
STARTED A GREAT INTERNSHIP
PROGRAM AS WELL. SO THERE'S
UNDER THE UMBRELLA OF
CONSERVATION, THERE'S A LOT YOU
CAN DO OUT THERE, RIGHT? THERE'S
LOTS OF ROLES THAT PEOPLE CAN
DO. AND SO WE'VE GOT SOME GREAT
INTERNS FOR PEOPLE WHO, YOU
KNOW, MAYBE I HAVE AN INTEREST
IN, IN POLICY OR LAW. SO THOSE
ARE NEW PATHWAYS WE'RE OPENING
UP AT THE C.C.C, WHICH ARE
REALLY EXCITING AS WELL. THANK
YOU. WHAT COLOR DO YOU CALL THAT
TIE? IT'S BEAUTIFUL. THANK YOU,
THAT'S AN AWESOME COLOR, ASK MY
WIFE. ASK THE WIFE. I DON'T KNOW
. YEAH. THANK YOU THOUGH I
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU. I'LL
BE EXCITED TO VOTE FOR IT. HEY,
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR. JONES, DO
YOU HAVE ANY ITEMS THAT YOU'D
LIKE TO ADD? OKAY. THANK YOU. SO
MUCH. A COUPLE ITEMS, MR.
DIRECTOR. I'D LIKE TO ADD A
FOCUS IN ON ONE, FOCUSING IN AT
HOME, AND THEN THE OTHER IS IN
REGARDS TO CORPS PAY, LOOK, I
KNOW THAT WE'RE IN A PRETTY
DIFFICULT BUDGET YEAR. I THINK
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
GET OUT OF IT AND THEN START
LOOKING AT A TURNAROUND HERE IN
THE NEXT, YOU KNOW, 24, 36
MONTHS, ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
AND I I'LL SPEAK FOR MYSELF. I
DON'T WANT TO PUT WORDS IN YOUR
MOUTH IS THE ISSUE OF CORPS PAY
WITH CORPS MEMBERS. BUT THEN THE
LEADS WITHIN THE CORPS. CAN YOU
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT?
AND AGAIN, THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT I'VE JUST NOTICED. HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH CORPS
MEMBERS. RIGHT. I THINK IT'S,
WANTING TO BE ABLE TO GET
ADDITIONAL FOLKS THAT LOOK MORE
LIKE THE REST OF CALIFORNIA INTO
THE CORPS. AND WHILE THE WORK
EXPERIENCE IS CRITICAL, LET'S
JUST BE CANDID. I THINK ONE OF
THE BEST THINGS THAT WE CAN DO
LIVE IN A VALUE STATEMENT IS PAY
FOLKS WHAT THEY'RE WORTH. THAT'S
RIGHT. SO CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THAT? BECAUSE THAT IS
A CONCERN THAT I HAVE GOING
FORWARD. THANK YOU. YEAH SINCE
MY ROLE AS A REGIONAL DEPUTY
DIRECTOR, WE MADE GREAT STRIDES
IN IMPROVING THE STIPEND THAT
CORPS MEMBERS GET. I THINK IT
NOW SITS AROUND 2814 A MONTH.
IT'S WHERE IT'S AT, THAT IS NOT
AT FAST FOOD PRICES, WHICH IS
$20 AN HOUR, BUT I THINK THERE
IS AN INCREDIBLE VALUE THAT THE
C.C.C. PRESENTS. AND I THINK
THAT PEOPLE ARE PAYING ATTENTION
TO THAT AND THAT WE SEE THAT IN
OUR IN OUR LONG WAIT LIST. SO
BEYOND THE PAY, THERE'S ALSO THE
MEDICAL INSURANCE THAT IS
PROVIDED. THERE ARE THE
SCHOLARSHIP OPPORTUNITIES. AND
SO I AGREE WITH YOU. I WOULD
LOVE TO GET MORE MORE MONEY AND
MORE FUNDING FOR FOLKS INTO
PEOPLE'S POCKETS BECAUSE THEY
CERTAINLY DESERVE IT. AND MORE.
AND WE'LL CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THAT AND IMPROVE THAT WHEN WE
CAN. YEAH, I THINK AND THEN
THERE'S A COMPASSION ISSUE. I
THINK THAT YOU ALSO HAVE JUST
WORKING WITH OUR OWN BUDGET
STAFF, TAKING A LOOK AT WHAT YOU
HAVE CORPS MEMBERS MAKING VERSUS
THE LEADS AS WELL. RIGHT. AND
AGAIN, THIS IS SOMETHING THAT,
THAT I KNOW OUR BUDGET TEAM HAS
BEEN LOOKING AT. OBVIOUSLY,
AGAIN, IT'S A TOUGH BUDGET YEAR,
BUT AT 2800 BUCKS A MONTH
DOESN'T CUT IT. RIGHT? I MEAN,
THE AVERAGE, MINIMUM WAGE WORKER
IN THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA,
FOR EXAMPLE, HAS TO WORK THREE
FULL TIME JOBS ON THE NORTH
COAST. IT'S TWO FULL TIME JOBS,
RIGHT? SO AGAIN, I KNOW WHAT THE
MOTTO IS, BUT JUST BEING SUPER
HONEST ABOUT IT, JUST THE COST
OF RENT ALONE, IT'S TOUGH. I
THINK LONGER TERM, AGAIN, I'M
NOT TRYING TO PUT WORDS IN YOUR
MOUTH OR PRESSURE YOU TO SAY
SOMETHING YOU DON'T WANT TO SAY,
BUT I DO THINK IT'S AN ISSUE,
RIGHT THAT WE'RE GOING TO NEED
TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS AS A
STATE. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR RAISING THAT, YOU'RE
BEING VERY SAFE. I TOTALLY GET
IT. NO BUT NO, HONESTLY, IT'S IT
NEEDS TO BE NEEDS TO BE SAID.
IT'S A THING IN THE ROOM. AND
ALSO, YOU KNOW, THE RESIDENTIAL
PROGRAM IS PRETTY INCREDIBLE.
AND THAT IS BECAUSE WE HAVE SUCH
A WAIT LIST FOR RESIDENTIAL
PROGRAM, WHICH, YOU KNOW, 500
BUCKS GETS YOU YOUR ROOM, YOUR
BOARD, AND BECAUSE THERE'S SUCH
A LIST FOR THAT, I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT AND VITAL. AND YOU
STRUCK A NERVE. I HEAR YOU, I'M
GOING TO SWITCH SUBJECTS. OKAY?
I THINK IT'S REALLY EXCITING IN
REGARDS TO, TAKING OVER THE OLD
EUREKA ARMORY. RIGHT AND IT'S
ALSO IN THIS REALLY CENTRAL AREA
WHERE YOU HAVE THE SEQUOIA PARK
ZOO. YOU GOT THE SCHOOL, YOU GOT
SEQUOIA PARK AS WELL. IT'S
UNDERUTILIZED, NÓ THAT, THERE'S
A DEAL FOR THE NEXT FEW YEARS TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE SOME EQUIPMENT
ON THE GROUNDS AND A SHARED
SPACE, IF YOU WILL, WITH THE
GUARD, BUT LONG TERM. RIGHT. I
THINK THAT IS A REALLY UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE CORPS TO BE
ABLE TO EXPAND THE FOOTPRINT.
THAT'S RIGHT. ABSOLUTELY. WE'RE
REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO IT. SO
THE FORTUNA CENTER HAS EXPANDED
THE FIRE CREW OVER THERE IS
PERMANENT. WE PUT ON SOME NEW
ASSETS WITH THAT PROPERTY. AND
SO THE BACKCOUNTRY TRAILS
PROGRAM AND THE WATERSHED
STEWARDS PROGRAM HAS BEEN
LOOKING FOR A NEW HOME. WE FOUND
A PARTICULAR PROPERTY, BUT WE'VE
ENTERED INTO AN AGREEMENT WITH
THE MILITARY DEPARTMENT. AND
THIS IS THIS IS AN AWESOME
OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR GROUP, AND
IF YOU JUST WANT TO GO INTO RAMP
UP TIME, REALISTICALLY, WHAT DO
YOU THINK IN REGARDS TO
TRANSITION REALLY, REALLY QUICK,
AS SOON AS IT'S SIGNED ON, WE'RE
READY TO GO. READY TO MOVE. GOT
IT. THAT'S GREAT NEWS. AND
AGAIN, A REALLY CRITICAL, PIECE
OF THE PUZZLE IN THAT WHOLE
SECTION OF TOWN. SO AND IT'S
BEEN NO, I'M NOT TRYING TO THROW
STONES AGAINST THE MILITARY
DEPARTMENT, BUT JUST YOU CUT IN
THE WEEDS HAS BEEN A GAME
CHANGER. THANK YOU SO, YEAH,
THAT THEY WERE AS TALL AS
REDWOODS. SO SO EXCITED TO MOVE
IN. YEAH. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. PLEASE
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR, I
APOLOGIZE. I'M DOING DOUBLE DUTY
ON COMMITTEES, SO I FORGIVE ME.
IT WAS NOT RUDE TO LEAVE. I JUST
HAD ANOTHER OBLIGATION, I, THANK
YOU FIRST FOR MY WORDS. YOU GAVE
ME THE C.C.C. GAVE ME AN AWARD
LAST A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO. IS
REALLY HONORED TO RECEIVE IT. I
WORK REALLY WELL WITH DAVID IN
KERN COUNTY, AND I THINK HE'S
INCREDIBLE. I WANT TO FOCUS A
LITTLE BIT ON THE SECOND CHANCE
ISSUE AND THE REASON WHY,
OBVIOUSLY, AND I KNOW MY
COLLEAGUES GET TIRED OF ME
SAYING THIS, BUT THE OIL
INDUSTRY USED TO PROVIDE JOBS TO
55% OF THE PEOPLE IN THE OIL
INDUSTRY WERE SECOND CHANCERS,
MAKING QUITE A BIT OF MONEY. AND
NOW THOSE JOBS ARE LEAVING THE
STATE, SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
ABILITY TO STILL OFFER SECOND
CHANCES AND OPPORTUNITY TO BE
ABLE TO. AND WHEN I SAY SECOND
CHANCERS, I MEAN FORMERLY
INCARCERATED, WHICH IS THE
CORRECT WORD, I LIKE HIM TO HAVE
SECOND CHANCES, BUT WHAT ARE
YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT THE PROGRAM
AND CAN YOU EXPAND IT SO THAT,
THESE INDIVIDUALS HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO STAY OUT, PROVIDE
FOR THEIR FAMILIES? I MEAN, I
KNOW YOU'RE NOT PAYING THEM THE
PRO TEM JUST ADDRESS THE ISSUE.
$100,000 A YEAR, 80,000, LIKE
WE'RE PAYING THEM. WE'RE PAYING
THEM IN THE OIL INDUSTRY. BUT
HOW, HOW DO YOU ADDRESS THAT? SO
THAT THEY HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
KNOW THAT THERE'S SOMETHING ELSE
BETTER OUT THERE THAN GOING BACK
TO PRISON? THANK YOU FOR THAT.
SO THE MIDDLE NAME OF THE CÁC IS
A SECOND CHANCE. AND THAT'S WHAT
OUR WE'RE ALL ABOUT, WHICH IS
THE GROWTH AND DEVELOPMENT OF A
YOUNG PERSON. AND A PERSON MAKES
MISTAKES AND CHALLENGES AND YOU
NEED THAT SECOND CHANCE. AND SO
WHAT FOLKS MIGHT BE INTERESTED
TO KNOW IS THAT WE'VE HAD A LONG
STANDING, RELATIONSHIP AND
SUPPORT OF FOLKS WHO ARE ON
PROBATION AND PAROLE AND
FORMERLY INCARCERATED, AND THOSE
FOLKS COME TO OUR PROGRAM AND
THEY DO VERY, VERY WELL IN OUR
PROGRAM. SO FOR US, WE WILL
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THEM, UPLIFT
THEM. AND IT IS A LAUNCH PAD
INTO THEIR THEIR NEXT RIGHT
STEP, WHATEVER THAT IS GOING TO
BE. AND THERE ARE TONS OF
OPPORTUNITIES WITHIN THE C.C.C.
THERE'S ENERGY, THERE'S FIRE,
THERE'S CULINARY, THERE'S
BACKCOUNTRY, THERE'S WATER, AND
THAT'S AVAILABLE TO ALL OF THEM.
AGAIN, THE THING TO BE ABLE TO
SERVE IN THE C.C.C. IS JUST A
MOTIVATION FOR HARD WORK,
SELF-IMPROVEMENT AND,
DEVELOPMENT AND SERVICE AND
THAT'S IT. AND SOFT SKILLS. I
THINK IF YOU CAN TEACH SOMEBODY
SOFT SKILLS AND THEY CAN ADOPT
THOSE, THEN, I MEAN, YOU CAN BE
THE BEST WELDER IN THE WORLD,
BUT IF I CAN'T GET YOU TO SHOW
UP FOR WORK OR BE ON TIME, IT'S
KIND OF IRRELEVANT HOW GOOD YOUR
SKILLS ARE. SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE SOFT SKILL
TRAINING THAT YOU GUYS DO AS
WELL. I FOLLOW THAT, THANK YOU,
SO LAST WEEK, I THINK, OR THE
WEEK BEFORE ENROLLS, WE HAD THE
FIRE MARSHAL, HERE AND HE TALKED
ABOUT THE PARTNERSHIPS WITH CAL
FIRE. AND, CAN YOU TALK ABOUT
THE ADVANTAGES AND IF THERE ARE
DISADVANTAGES, I WOULD THINK IT
WOULD PRETTY WELL BE POSITIVE.
BUT CAN YOU TALK ABOUT THE
ADVANTAGES AND DISADVANTAGES IN
THE PARTNERSHIP THAT C.C.C. HAS
WITH CAL FIRE? I LOVE OUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH CAL FIRE. IT IS
THE BLUEPRINT. IT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE'RE USING FOR OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR OTHER
STATE AGENCIES AS WELL, CHIEF
BERLANT REFERENCED LAST WEEK
THAT, YOU KNOW, THEY'RE SOAKING
UP A LOT OF OUR, OUR
FIREFIGHTERS, WHICH IS A RHYTHM
THAT WE'VE GOT ACCUSTOMED TO,
WHICH IS COMPLETELY GREAT. SO
WHAT MIGHT SEEM LIKE ON ITS
FACE, HARD OR CHALLENGING FOR
US? TO ME, THAT MEANS OUR
PROGRAM IS EXACTLY RUNNING AS IT
SHOULD. I'M VERY PROUD THAT WE
HAVE 100 CORPS MEMBERS GOING TO
JOIN THE FIRE SERVICES AND
COUNTING, AND WHEN OUR OUR CREWS
, WHEN OUR FOLKS LEAVE US, WE
REPLENISH THEM WITH MORE FOLKS.
SO THERE'S A BIG INTEREST OUT
THERE FOR FOLKS JOINING THE FIRE
SERVICES. AND SO IT'S A GOOD
PROBLEM TO HAVE. AND IT'S A
GREAT RELATIONSHIP. THANK YOU.
AND NOTHING I MEAN I ADMIRABLY
SUPPORT FIREFIGHTERS. I THINK
THEY'RE INCREDIBLE. AND THEY DO
THEIR JOB AND NOTHING AGAINST
THEM WHATSOEVER SHAPE OR FORM.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU THAT A FEW
YEARS AGO, OUR RANCH GOT CAUGHT
ON FIRE AND IT WAS A C.C.C.
CREWS THAT WENT OUT AT NIGHT TO
PUT OUT ALL THE HOSPITAL, THE
HOT SPOTS, AND THEY WERE
CARRYING BACKPACKS AND TOOLS AND
EQUIPMENT AND WORKING ALL NIGHT
LONG TO SPOT THOSE FLARE UPS
THAT COULD POSSIBLY START THE
RANCH ON FIRE AGAIN. AND THEY
WERE HARD AND AGAIN FIREFIGHTERS
HARD WORKING, DEDICATED. BUT
THAT C.C.C. CREW THAT WAS THERE
AND THEY DIDN'T KNOW WHO I WAS,
THEY DIDN'T KNOW WHOSE PROPERTY
IT WAS. RIGHT, THEY WERE OUT
THERE. AND I MEAN, I'M TALKING
12 HOURS ALL NIGHT LONG, MAKING
SURE THAT THE RANCH WAS SAFE.
AND I'M SURE THEY DO THAT TO
EVERY PROPERTY THAT THEY TAKE
CARE OF. SO COMPLIMENTARY TO
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND MAKING SURE
THAT THEY DO A REALLY GOOD JOB.
SO THANK YOU, I APPRECIATE THAT.
I'LL BRING THAT BACK. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. MADAM VICE CHAIR WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS, PLEASE. MR. JONES,
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DIRECTOR.
THANKS FOR COMING THIS MORNING.
I DIDN'T HAVE ANY REALLY
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS REGARDING YOU
OR THE OR THE JOB THAT YOU'RE
BEING APPOINTED TO, BUT I DO
HAVE, I'VE GOT SOME BUDGET NOTES
, AND I JUST SOMETHING JUST
JUMPED OUT AT ME AS I WAS
LOOKING THROUGH THIS. SO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED 2425 BUDGET
IS A TOTAL OF ABOUT 155 MILLION,
100 MILLION IS GENERAL FUND.
AND, THE C.C.C. GETS
REIMBURSEMENTS OF 44 MILLION CAP
AND TRADE 12 MILLION. THE
BUDGET. SO HERE'S WHAT JUMPED
OUT AT ME. THE BUDGET PROPOSES
502 ADMINISTRATOR AND SUPPORT
POSITIONS. IN ADDITION TO THE
1634 CORE MEMBERS IN 2425, THE
NUMBER THAT JUMPED OUT IS FIVE
502 ADMINISTRATORS. THAT'S THAT
SEEMS LIKE A LOT OF
ADMINISTRATION FOR 1600 FOLKS
THAT ARE ACTUALLY FEET AND HANDS
ON THE GROUND DOING THE WORK.
AND OBVIOUSLY I'M MISSING
SOMETHING. SO AND ARE YOU ABLE
TO SPEAK TO THAT TODAY OR CAN
YOU GET BACK TO US ON IT OR I'LL
GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT, BECAUSE
I'M NOT QUITE SURE WHAT THAT
WHAT THAT NUMBER IS EMANATING
FROM. THAT SOUNDS LIKE THE
NUMBER OF OUR, OUR STAFF THAT WE
CURRENTLY WE HAVE. BUT IT'S NOT
A NEW ASK. BUT WE'LL CERTAINLY
FOLLOW UP ON THAT. WELL YEAH.
I'M NOT IT'S NOT SHOWING HERE
THAT IT'S A NEW ASK. IT'S I
THINK IT'S TRADITIONAL, BUT IF.
YEAH, I'D LIKE TO SEE SOME,
JUSTIFICATION FOR 502
ADMINISTERED AND SUPPORT PEOPLE
FOR THAT NUMBER, WE'LL LOOK INTO
THAT FOR YOU. OKAY, I APPRECIATE
THAT. THANK YOU. HOW MANY PLEASE
. APPROXIMATELY HOW MANY CORE?
CORE PEOPLE? ABOUT 1600. OKAY.
SO THOSE NUMBERS ARE CORRECT.
OKAY ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE?
ONE MORE THING, PLEASE. I'M
SORRY. WHEN WOULD YOU ANTICIPATE
BEING ABLE TO GET THAT BACK TO
US, WITHIN, WITHIN THE WEEK OR
SO. PERFECT THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. SO WHY DON'T WE DO THIS,
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO EACH OF
YOU, TO BE ABLE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE DIRECTOR, MR. DIRECTOR, WHAT
WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SAY IS,
LET'S JUST SAY BY THE END OF
NEXT WEEK, BY NEXT FRIDAY, IF
YOU COULD JUST GET THE COMMITTEE
THROUGH, LISA CHIN, AND THEN
SHE'LL DISTRIBUTE TO EACH OF THE
OFFICES IS THE ANSWER BY MR.
JONES. HAPPY TO DO IT FOR YOU SO
THAT WOULD BE A DATE OF THE
14TH, THAT WE'RE GOING TO NEED
TO BE ABLE TO GET THAT BACK IN
WRITING. YOU GOT IT. APPRECIATE
THAT. THANK YOU. SO MUCH, LEADER
JONES. IS THAT APPROPRIATE FOR
YOU? THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND
THEN, MISS CHIN, YOU ALSO FOLLOW
UP WITH THE DIRECTOR'S OFFICE ON
THAT. THANK YOU SO MUCH. ALL
RIGHT. WHY DON'T WE DO THIS.
LET'S OPEN IT UP FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. WE'RE GOING TO LOOK TO
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS CONFIRMATION. IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD. WE'RE
GOING TO ASK YOU TO PLEASE STATE
YOUR FIRST AND LAST NAME, ALONG
WITH YOUR POTENTIAL
ORGANIZATION. WE'RE GOING TO ASK
YOU TO PLEASE KEEP YOUR COMMENTS
TO 30S OR LESS. WELCOME SIR. HI.
MY NAME IS ADAM SUMMERS. I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE C.C.C.
FOUNDATION. I WORKED WITH DAVID
MURATSUCHI YEARS AGO. I WORKED
THROUGHOUT, BRUCE SAITO'S TENURE
AT THE C.C.C. AND I'VE WORKED
WITH JARED PATTON WHEN HE WAS A
REGIONAL DEPUTY DIRECTOR. AND
SINCE NOVEMBER OF THIS YEAR, AND
I SUPPORT THIS APPOINTMENT FULLY
WITHOUT EXCEPTION. I THINK THAT
JARED IS INTELLIGENT,
COMPASSIONATE, VISIONARY IN THIS
AREA AND A GREAT FACE FOR THE
C.C.C. GOING FORWARD FOR THE
NEXT 50 YEARS. THEY HAVE AN
ANNIVERSARY IN TWO. SO FOR THE
NEXT 50, HE'S HE WOULD BE A GOOD
FACE FOR THIS ORGANIZATION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE
THOUGHT WE WERE GOING TO KEEP
THEM THERE FOR 50. THANK YOU.
SET THE STAGE ALL RIGHT THERE WE
GO. THANK YOU SO MUCH. WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON.
HI. MY NAME IS ANGEL MINER AND
I'M THE CEO OF CONSERVATION
CORPS NORTH BAY, AND SO WE ARE A
LOCAL CONSERVATION CORPS. WE DO
A LOT OF WORK AROUND ZERO WASTE
FOR OUR COMMUNITY, BUT WE ALSO
DO A LOT OF WORK AROUND FUELS
REDUCTION, WE ARE DOING TRAILS
CLEARING, A LOT OF SIMILAR
THINGS THAT ARE HAPPENING AT THE
C.C.C. AND THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS. WE ALSO LAUNCHED FIRE
FOUNDRY, WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT
HELPS UNDERSERVED YOUNG ADULTS,
WOMEN GET INTO THE FIRE SERVICE
WHERE THEY WOULDN'T HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY. INCLUDES HOUSING
INCLUDES A LOT OF THE WRAPAROUND
SUPPORT, THAT KIND OF MODELS
WHAT THE C.C.C. DOES. AND WHEN I
THINK ABOUT THOSE THINGS AND I
THINK ABOUT THE THINGS THAT,
THAT, THAT HE'S ALREADY DONE.
RIGHT, AND YOU THINK ABOUT THE
EXTRA FIREFIGHTERS THAT HAVE
BEEN BROUGHT ON BOARD, YOU TALK
ABOUT THE TRAINING THAT'S
ALREADY BEEN PUT IN PLACE FOR
THE LEADERS, AND FOR THE SENIOR
CORPS MEMBERS. AND HE'S OFFERING
THOSE TO OUR FOLKS, TOO. RIGHT.
SO THINGS THAT WE WOULDN'T HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO DO.
SO IT'S BRINGING THAT KIND OF
COMMUNITY TOGETHER FOR ALL OF
US. AND I THINK THESE ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT THINGS THAT WE PARTNER
TOGETHER. WE SERVE A LOT OF THE
SAME CONSTITUENTS. WE DO IT
SOMETIMES IN DIFFERENT WAYS. WE
ARE AS NONPROFITS, BUT THERE ARE
A LOT OF PLACES WHERE WE CAN
PARTNER, SHARE RESOURCES. WE'RE
WORKING ON EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES TOGETHER. AND SO I
THINK THAT PARTNERSHIP AND
LOOKING AT THAT GOING FORWARD,
AND THE OTHER THING I WANT TO
SAY IS, YOU KNOW, WE DID A GOV
ED DAY, MAYBE A COUPLE OF MONTHS
AGO. AND I REMEMBER HE CAME
AROUND, HE SAID HELLO, AND I
THOUGHT, OH, HE'S GOING TO DO
THE DRIVE BY AND SAY HI TO
EVERYBODY. AND, AND HE PROBABLY
HAS A LOT MORE IMPORTANT THINGS
TO DO. AND HE WAS THERE ALL DAY
AND HE TALKED TO EVERY ONE OF
OUR CORPS MEMBERS. AND HE WANTED
TO KNOW WHAT THEY WERE DOING AND
WHAT THEIR BACKGROUND WAS AND
WHAT THEY WANTED TO GET OUT OF
THIS. AND THAT'S NOT SOMETHING
YOU CAN FIND EASILY. AND SO I
CERTAINLY FULLY SUPPORT THIS
APPOINTMENT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU, MISS
MINER. APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE. THANK YOU SO MUCH. HI.
GOOD AFTERNOON. WELCOME. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS PAULA
BIRDSONG AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE SACRAMENTO
REGIONAL CONSERVATION CORPS.
GOOD TO SEE ALL OF YOUR FACES.
I'M HERE TO ASK YOU TO SUPPORT
JP PATTON AS THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS.
WE ARE SUPREMELY PROUD OF THE
WORK. HE HAS DONE IN HIS SHORT
TENURE, AND HIS VISION ALIGNS
WITH OUR LOCAL CORE. WE'RE ONE
OF 14 CORES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA, AND WE'RE HAPPY
THAT THE WORK THAT WE CAN DO IN
PARTNERSHIP IS DEFINITELY IN
LINE WITH SUPPORTING AND
ENRICHING THE LIVES OF 18 TO 26
YEAR OLD AND SOMETIMES OLDER.
FOR THE C.C.C. MEMBERS OVER HIS
TENURE, MR. PATTON HAS IS
RELAUNCHED THE GLOBAL CORPS AND
EXPANDED THE OPERATIONS IN A
NUMBER OF COUNTRIES. I HAPPEN TO
BE IN HONDURAS AND I CAN ATTEST
JUST A MONTH AGO OF THE WORK
THAT THE CORPS IS DOING THERE. I
COMPLIMENTED A YOUNG MAN FOR THE
WORK HE WAS DOING ON THE ROADS,
AND HE SAID HE WAS WITH THE
CORPS, AND I WENT, STOP. YOU
COULD NOT BE. THAT'S WHAT I DO.
AND WE HAD A GREAT CONVERSATION,
NOT KNOWING. AND I SAID, THAT'S
JARED'S DOING. I KNOW IT IS. MR.
PATTON IS ALSO ENHANCED
CONTRACTING OPPORTUNITIES WITH
THE CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCE
AGENCY, AND WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL
THAT THAT BOND IS GROWING AND
GROWING FOR ALL OF OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE IN OUR CAUSE.
ADDITIONALLY, MR. PATTON HAS
FACILITATED THE HIRING OF 87 NEW
FIREFIGHTERS SIGNIFICANTLY
BOOSTING THE FIRE RESPONSE
CAPABILITIES. THESE ARE JUST
SOME OF THE EXAMPLES OF WHY WE
THINK AND WE ARE SO PROUD OF THE
WORK THAT HAS HAPPENED AND THAT
WE BELIEVE WILL CONTINUE TO
HAPPEN UNDER HIS LEADERSHIP. SO
WE WHOLEHEARTEDLY AND
ENTHUSIASTICALLY AND SINCERELY
SUPPORT THE CONFIRMATION OF JP
PATTON. THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE'RE
GRATEFUL. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR WORDS TODAY. WELCOME, SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON. HOW ARE YOU
DOING? GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK
YOU, MY NAME IS STEPHEN ADDISON
AND I REPRESENT CIVIC CORPS.
WE'RE A LOCAL CONSERVATION CORPS
BASED OUT OF WEST OAKLAND, WE'RE
HERE IN SUPPORT OF JP PATTON FOR
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS. AS DIRECTOR,
MR. PATTON HAS FOCUSED ON
INCREASING CAREER PATHWAYS FOR
CORPS MEMBERS, CHAMPIONING
DIVERSITY, EQUITY AND INCLUSION,
AND EXPANDING THE CORPS GLOBAL
REACH OVER HIS TENURE. HIS
ACCOMPLISHMENTS HAVE BEEN MANY,
THE ONES THAT FOCUS ON
STRENGTHENING LOCAL CORES HAVE
AN IMPORTANT IMPACT ON THE MANY
URBAN AND RURAL CONSERVATION
CORPS, THE MANY RURAL AND,
SORRY, THE LIVES OF MANY URBAN
AND RURAL CORPS MEMBERS NOT
DIRECTLY TOUCHED BY THE C.C.C.
MR. PATTON HAS HELPED TO ENHANCE
OUR CONTRACTING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCE
AGENCIES, WHICH HAS AFFORDED US
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH
MANY DIFFERENT LAND MANAGERS
THROUGHOUT THE EAST BAY AND
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. MR. PATTON
HAS ALSO HELPED TO EXPAND THE
TRAINING FOR C.C.C. CAN OFFER
LOCAL CONSERVATION CORPS, WHICH
HELPS US READY OUR CORPS MEMBERS
AND STAFF TO BETTER SERVE THE
PEOPLE AND LANDS OF CALIFORNIA.
I STARTED MY JOURNEY IN THE
CONSERVATION WORK 30 YEARS AGO
WHEN I JOINED THE C.C.C, IT WAS
ONE OF THE MOST CONSEQUENTIAL
DECISIONS I'VE MADE IN MY LIFE.
I BELIEVE MR. PATTON WILL
CONTINUE THE LEGACY AND THE
TRADITION OF THE C.C.C.
BETTERING THE LIVES OF THE YOUNG
ADULTS AND THE CALIFORNIANS THAT
WE SERVE. THANK YOU, AND BECAUSE
OF THIS, WE SUPPORT YOUR
NOMINATION. AND THANK YOU FOR
ALL THE WORK YOU'VE DONE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
WORDS. FROM ONE DIRECTOR TO
ANOTHER. THIS WELCOME. GOOD.
GOOD AFTERNOON. COMMITTEE CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS BRUCE
SAITO, RETIRED CIVIL SERVANT.
AND I'M HERE IN TOTAL SUPPORT OF
THE APPOINTMENT OF JARED PATTON.
JP, I'M GOING TO HARD HATS TODAY
. ONE IS A HARD HAT. AS A BOARD
MEMBER OF THE SOMETHING CALLED
THE CORPS NETWORK. CORPS NETWORK
IS A NATIONAL MEMBERSHIP
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING 140
CONSERVATION CORPS AND THE
CORPS, INITIALLY, SUPPORT ATED
JP'S APPOINTMENT AND NOW AS A
SUPPORTING HIS, COMMITMENT TO
THE C.C.C. AND TO COMMIT TO THE
STATE BECAUSE HE BRINGS A VAST
KNOWLEDGE, NOT JUST OF
EXPERIENCE IN CORPS PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA, BUT AND NOT JUST
LOCALLY, BUT ALSO NATIONWIDE,
WHERE HE SERVES ON THE CORPS
COUNCIL OR THE CORPS NETWORK
BOARD AS THE CORPS COUNCIL
MEMBER. AND THE SECOND AD I'M
WEARING IS ON A VERY PERSONAL
LEVEL, AS A FORMER DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS, I'VE HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
WITNESSING FIRSTHAND THE
COMMITMENT, THE DEDICATION AND
THE TRUE SINCERITY OF THE WORK
OF JP. AND AS ANGEL SAID, IT'S
NOT JUST THAT HE HAS A GREAT
KNOWLEDGE AND ABILITY TO DIRECT
AND MANAGE 503 ADMINISTRATIVE
AND 1600 CORPS MEMBERS. BUT THAT
HE ALSO DOES THAT WITH A REAL
SENSE OF SECURITY, SINCERITY,
HONESTY AND INTEGRITY. AND I
THINK BECAUSE OF ALL THOSE
REASONS AND THEN SOME, JP WILL
MAKE A FANTASTIC CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS DIRECTOR.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MR. DIRECTOR. IT'S GOOD TO SEE
YOU. APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS.
HEY. GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
NICHOLAS MAZZOTTI, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LOCAL CONSERVATION CORPS, WHICH
IS MADE UP OF 14 LOCAL COMMUNITY
CAUSE THROUGHOUT THE STATE,
CERTIFIED BY THE C.C.C. I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF WONDERFUL
COMMENTS MADE ABOUT JP PATTEN
ALREADY, SO I'LL KEEP IT BRIEF,
BUT JP, SINCE HIS APPOINTMENT AS
ACTING DIRECTOR SINCE NOVEMBER
2023, HE'S PUT A LOT OF WORK
TOWARDS, YOU KNOW, BUILDING UP
THE CORPS MOVEMENT AND AT THE
CORE OF THAT HAS BEEN A
WONDERFUL RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
LOCAL CONSERVATION CORPS, WE
HAVE A LONG HISTORY WORKING WITH
THE C.C.C. AND HE HAS HAD A
STRONG COMMITMENT TO HELPING US
FROM DAY ONE. AND FOR THESE
REASONS, WE ARE EXCITED TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH HIM AND
ENCOURAGE YOU ALL TO VOTE TO
CONFIRM HIM. SO THANK YOU. SO
MUCH. GRATEFUL FOR YOUR WORDS
TODAY. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO
DO A LAST CALL. THANK YOU ALL
FOR THOSE BEAUTIFUL WORDS. WE'D
LIKE TO WAIT TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT. ALL
RIGHT. WE'RE NOW GOING TO LOOK
TO ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO COME FORWARD, WHO
MAY BE IN OPPOSITION. IF YOU
COULD PLEASE STEP FORWARD TO THE
PODIUM. WE'RE GOING TO DO A LAST
CALL FOR OPPOSITION HERE. AND
SEEING NONE, WE'RE GOING TO
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE TO BE
ABLE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY LAST
MINUTE DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
WE'RE ALSO WELCOME A MOTION,
PLEASE, I WOULD MOVE WE CONFIRM
JP PATTEN AS DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
LAIRD. MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL? MISS
MCGUIRE. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE GROVE
. EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE. JONES A
JONES. AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. UNCLE THAT'S A40 VOTE ON
CALL. FOUR ZERO. VOTE ON CALL,
MR. DIRECTOR. WE'LL GET, MADAM
VICE CHAIR ON TO THE VOTE ROLL,
I WILL SAY IN EARLY. KNOCK ON
WOOD. CONGRATULATIONS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. I'M SURE SILAS IS ALSO
REALLY PROUD OF YOU AS WELL. SO.
YEAH. THANK YOU SO MUCH. ALL
RIGHT. MORE TO COME. THANK YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A TWO MINUTE
BREAK, ALLOW FOR, A LITTLE BIT
OF A BREAK FOR OUR AMAZING COURT
REPORTER. IF THAT WORKS, AND
THEN AS WE TAKE THIS BREAK,
WE'RE GOING TO WELCOME MR. BRAD.
COME ON. FORWARD THAT WILL BE
OUR NEXT POTENTIAL APPOINTMENT.
TWO MINUTES, PLEASE. OKAY.
ALL RIGHT, LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
WE'RE GOING TO COME BACK
TOGETHER. WE'RE GOING TO WELCOME
MR. BRAD TO COMMITTEE, MOVING
FORWARD WITH THE AGRICULTURAL
LABOR RELATIONS BOARD. BRAD,
IT'S REALLY GOOD TO SEE YOU. MY
GOODNESS. A PLEASURE TO BE HERE.
CHAIRMAN MCGUIRE. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, IT'S A GREAT HONOR TO
BE ON THE ALRB, I FEEL VERY
GRATEFUL THAT THE GOVERNOR,
CONFIDENT ENOUGH IN MY ABILITIES
TO REAPPOINT ME, I WANT TO THANK
YOUR STAFF AND MEETING WITH
THEM. I HAVE TO CONFESS, AS MORE
OF A REUNION THAN A GRILLING,
BUT. OR AT LEAST THAT'S HOW I
FELT THE GRILLING. SO, YEAH. OR
I'VE BEEN GRILLED ENOUGH THAT,
IT DOESN'T MUCH MATTER. BUT
ANYWAY, AND ALSO, I WANT TO
THANK THE GOVERNOR'S STAFF
WHO'VE BEEN VERY, VERY, VERY
HELPFUL TO ME AND, AND THE LABOR
AGENCY STAFF WHO HAVE HELPED
GUIDE ME ALONG THE WAY. I WANT
TO THANK THE COURT REPORTER. I
REPRESENTED COURT REPORTERS FOR
MANY YEARS. I KNOW HOW HARD YOU
WORK. I KNOW WHAT YOU DO, AND
PROBABLY YOU DON'T GET THANKED
TOO OFTEN BY WITNESSES. BUT, I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU. I WANT
TO SAY SOMETHING VERY BRIEF
ABOUT THAT AND THEN ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS. BUT I WANT TO SAY
SOMETHING BRIEF BUT IMPORTANT.
50 YEARS AGO, ALMOST 50 YEARS
AGO, WHEN THE NLRB ALRP LÀ WAS
ENACTED, LABOR RELATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA, AGRICULTURE WAS
CONTENTIOUS AND HIGHLY
CONTENTIOUS, AND IT WAS OFTEN
VIOLENT. AND I THINK WE FORGET
THAT BECAUSE IT'S STILL
CONTENTIOUS. BUT IT'S NOT
VIOLENT. AND THE NLRB'S ROLE.
REALLY, WHEN YOU KIND OF GO TO
THE 50,000 FOOT LEVEL, ITS ROLE
IS TO HELP ENSURE THAT DISPUTES
IN AGRICULTURE, HOWEVER
CONTENTIOUS THEY MAY BE BETWEEN
WORKERS AND EMPLOYERS, BETWEEN
UNIONS AND EMPLOYERS, THAT THEIR
DIFFERENCES ARE RESOLVED
PEACEFULLY AND THAT THERE'S
PEACE IN RURAL CALIFORNIA NOW.
IT'S BEEN LONG ENOUGH THAT I
DON'T THINK WE REMEMBER SO
EASILY WHAT THAT WAS LIKE. I
REMEMBER BECAUSE IT WAS IN MY
SORT OF TEENS AND YOUNG ADULT
LIFE IN COLLEGE. I MEAN, I SAW
THAT AND REMEMBER IT ALL, AND,
BUT IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME AND A
LOT OF OUR CASES, I MEAN, PEOPLE
ASK ME, WHAT ARE MOST OF YOUR
CASES LIKE? WELL, MOST OF OUR
CASES ACTUALLY DON'T INVOLVE
UNIONS FIGHTING WITH EMPLOYERS.
THEY ACTUALLY INVOLVE WORKERS
WHO ON THEIR OWN, IN THE
MAJORITY OF THEM HAVE AN ISSUE.
THEY RAISE THAT ISSUE WITH THE
EMPLOYER. THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
DRINKING WATER. A LOT OF THEM
ARE HEALTH AND SAFETY ISSUES
THAT THEY RAISE. THE EMPLOYER
MAY REACT LIKE I, YOU KNOW, GO
BACK TO WORK OR I DON'T WANT TO
LISTEN TO IT OR YOU DON'T HAVE A
PROBLEM. AND SOME BODY GETS
RETALIATED AGAINST OR ALLEGES
THAT THEY'RE RETALIATED AGAINST,
OR THE WORKERS WALK OFF THE JOB
AND SAY, THAT'S IT. YOU KNOW, WE
CAN'T TAKE IT, AND WE'RE THERE
TO RESOLVE THAT DISPUTE, TO
FIGURE OUT WHO'S RIGHT, WHO'S
WRONG, PUT PEOPLE BACK TO WORK
IF THEY NEED TO BE PUT BACK TO
WORK, AND WE'RE THERE TO WEAR
THOSE BLINDERS AND THAT
BLINDFOLD OF JUSTICE, WHICH IS
WE'RE NOT THERE TO TAKE ONE SIDE
OR ANOTHER. WE'RE THERE TO
UPHOLD THE LAW, FOLLOW THE LAW
AND APPLY THE LAW FAIRLY WITHOUT
BIAS. AND THAT'S WHAT I HOPE I'M
DOING. I'M VERY LUCKY TO BE ON
THIS BOARD. WE HAPPEN TO HAVE
FIVE BOARD MEMBERS WHO I'M SURE
YOU ALL KNOW THIS ONE TOXIC
PERSONALITY CAN RUIN ANY KIND OF
A COMMITTEE, BUT OUR BOARD
HAPPENS TO HAVE FIVE
EXTRAORDINARILY, VERY DEDICATED
PEOPLE, AND WE HAVE A VERY
COLLEGIAL BOARD AND DEAL WITH
OUR ISSUES. AND IT'S A PLEASURE
TO WORK THERE. WE HAVE AN
AMAZING STAFF. SO I WANT TO JUST
WANTED TO SAY THAT AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU. AND I'M PREPARED TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH, MR. BRADFORD. GRATEFUL.
WHAT WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO DO
IS OPEN IT UP FOR QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS, DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
FROM COMMITTEE. WE'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO ANSWER, ADVANCE A
COMMENT OR QUESTION. SURE. MADAM
VICE CHAIR, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, THANK YOU
FOR MEETING WITH ME. I KNOW
AFTER WATCHING THOSE OTHERS,
YOU'RE LIKE, OH, DANG. SHE CAME
BACK NOW, I HAD A GOOD TIME.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
SPENDING ALL THAT TIME WITH ME.
I REALLY DO APPRECIATE IT. SO
OBVIOUSLY I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
AB 2183 AND AB 113, SPECIFIC
PLEA, YOU KNOW, ALMOST A YEAR
AFTER THE GOVERNOR SIGNED 2183,
HE SIGNED AB 113. AND I REALIZE
THAT YOU ARE JUST THE
IMPLEMENTATION PART OF THE
POLICY. THèC, BUT YOU GAVE A
VERY GOOD EXPLANATION IN MY
OFFICE ABOUT THE CARD CHECK
BILL, SPECIFICALLY WHAT WE
REFERENCE AS CARD CHECK. AND I'D
LIKE YOU TO GO THROUGH THAT
PROCESS FOR THE BENEFIT OF THE
PUBLIC, AGAIN, TALKING ABOUT THE
PROCESS OF HOW YOU USED TO BE
ABLE TO, SOLVE THE OR AGREE ON
SOMETHING BEFORE YOU ACTUALLY
HAD THE VOTE AND GO THROUGH THAT
PROCESS OF WHAT THE CARD
ACTUALLY MEANS. NOW, IT'S NOT
JUST A CARD. YES. SO THE, THE
BILL THAT WAS PASSED BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND SIGNED AB 113 IS
A NEW PROCESS. REALLY. IT'S KIND
OF UNIQUE IN LABOR RELATIONS.
IT'S NOT UNPRECEDENTED. MILLIONS
OF WORKERS HAVE BEEN CERTIFIED
TO BE IN REP, PRESENTED BY A
UNION THROUGH CARD CHECK
PROCESSES THERE. BUT THEY'RE A
LITTLE DIFFERENT THE WAY THEY
WORK UNDER THE NATIONAL LABOR
RELATIONS ACT. WE HAVE SOMETHING
SIMILAR AT PERB, AND, AND, AND
THE WAY THIS SYSTEM WORKS, JUST
SO YOU UNDERSTAND IT, IS THAT
THE RATHER THAN A TRADITIONAL
SECRET BALLOT ELECTION, WE SHARE
A THE BOARD AGENT SHOW UP AT THE
EMPLOYER'S PLACE OF BUSINESS ON
A SPECIFIC DAY, YOU KNOW, WITH A
TABLE AND CHAIRS AND A BALLOT
BOX AND A SIGN VOTE HERE, AND
CONDUCT AN ELECTION IN WHICH
EACH PERSON COMES UP, THEY'RE
CHECKED OFF A LIST, AND, AND,
AND BUT ALL ISSUES RELATED TO
OBJECTIONS THAT SOMEBODY MIGHT
HAVE, LIKE, WAIT A MINUTE. YOU
ARE A SUPERVISOR AND YOU'RE NOT
ELIGIBLE TO VOTE OR IN THE CASE
OF AGRICULTURE, YOU HAVE TO WORK
IN THE PEAK WEEKS OF WORK OF THE
EMPLOYER. WELL, WAIT A MINUTE.
YOU WEREN'T IN THE PEAK PERIOD
OR WHATEVER. ALL THAT IS
RESOLVED BEFORE. BEFORE THE
VOTES ARE COUNTED AND THE UNION
IS CERTIFIED OR NOT CERTIFIED AS
THE WINNER. IN THIS SYSTEM, YOU
DO, YOU GET AN AUTHORIZATION
CARD, AND I KNOW YOU'RE USED TO
THIS AS LEGISLATORS, BUT
SOMETIMES WE SPEAK IN EUPHEMISMS
, LAWS SPEAK IN IN EUPHEMISMS.
AND THE THING IS SORT OF A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT THAN IT MAY
BE DESCRIBED. AUTHORIZATION CARD
IS TRADITIONALLY WHAT OCCURS IN
LABOR RELATIONS. THAT. BUT IT'S
TRUE IN THE TRADITIONAL SECRET
BALLOT ELECTION, YOU TURN A
SUFFICIENT NUMBER OF THOSE INTO
THE GOVERNMENTAL AGENCY, AND
THAT TRIGGERS THE ELECTION. YOU
HAVE TO HAVE A 30% SHOWING OF
INTEREST. THE AUTHORIZATION
CARDS. NOW ARE THE BALLOT. AND
WE'RE DRAFTING REGULATIONS NOW.
RIGHT NOW THEY'RE IN THEY'RE
STILL IN THE, IN THE DISCUSSION
STAGE WHERE IT'S GOING BACK AND
FORTH BETWEEN THE PUBLIC COMMENT
AND REVISIONS. WE'RE GETTING
VERY CLOSE TO THE END, AND WE
INTEND AT LEAST OUR WHERE OUR
PROPOSAL IS NOW, THAT IT'S VERY
MADE VERY CLEAR, THIS CARD IS
YOUR BALLOT. AND ON THAT CARD SO
THAT WORKERS UNDERSTAND THEY'RE
NOT JUST AUTHORIZING THE UNION
TO REPRESENT THEM, THEY ARE
VOTING FOR THE UNION TO
REPRESENT THEM. THOSE CARDS,
WHEN THEY ARE TURNED IN UNDER
THIS PROCESS, THEY ARE COUNTED.
THERE IS AN INVESTIGATION THAT
THE OUR STAFF DOES WITHIN FIVE
DAYS, AND THEN THEY TALLY THOSE
CARDS. AND IF THE UNION HAS A
MAJORITY OF THE ELIGIBLE VOTERS,
THEY'RE CERTIFIED AS THE
REPRESENTATIVE. AND IF THEY
DON'T, THEY'RE NOT CERTIFIED
ONLY THEN DOES ARE OBJECTIONS
HEARD BY US. SO IT'S CERTIFIED
FIRST OBJECT AND THEN THE
OBJECTIONS, IF THEY'RE SUSTAINED
CAN UNDO THE CERTIFICATION. SO
THAT'S A THAT'S A SIGNIFICANTLY
DIFFERENT PROCESS THAN IT EXISTS
ELSEWHERE. AND WE'RE JUST
DEALING WITH IT. WE'VE HAD THE
FIRST THREE CASES. WE HAVEN'T
YET FINALIZED OUR REGULATIONS.
SO IT IT IS, EMERGING, BUT WE'RE
TRYING AS HARD AS WE CAN TO
FAITHFULLY, FOLLOW THE DIRECTION
OF THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
STATUTE. WE DON'T WRITE STATUTES
. WE DO WHAT YOU TELL US TO DO.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO. THANK YOU. THANK YOU, I JUST
I APPRECIATE THAT EXPLANATION
VERY MUCH. SO, BECAUSE I HAVE A
LOT OF COLLEAGUES IN THIS BILL
PASSES THAT IT WAS PART OF THE
SAME PROCESS, AND IT'S NOT THE
SAME PROCESS. IT'S ACTUALLY AN
ELECTION PROCESS, INSTEAD OF AN
INTEREST AND THEN A VOTE, IT'S A
AUTOMATIC ELECTION PROCESS WITH
THIS CARD CHECK, IS THERE
EDUCATION THAT IS GOING OUT? IS
THERE RESOURCES OR IS THERE
INFORMATION ON EDUCATION TO
EDUCATE THE FARM WORKERS?
BECAUSE UNDER THE TRADITIONAL
STANDARD, IF THEY WANTED TO
ELECT A UNION, THEY WOULD GO,
YES, I WANT TO HAVE A VOTE. BUT
WHAT THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND IS
THEY'RE VOTING AT THAT VERY
MOMENT. IS THERE AN EDUCATION
PROCESS OR IS THERE CURRICULUM
OR THERE? THERE IS INFORMATION
ON OUR WEBSITE. I MEAN, HOW MANY
PEOPLE READ IT? WE HAVE OUTREACH
STAFF. WE HAVE TO BE VERY
SENSITIVE ABOUT, EDUCATION IN
THE SENSE THAT IT WE'RE NEUTRAL.
SO WE HAVE TO EXPLAIN PEOPLE
WHAT THEIR RIGHTS ARE. BUT WE
CANNOT ENCOURAGE SOMEONE TO
SUPPORT OR NOT SUPPORT BEING
REPRESENTED BY A UNION. SO WE
HAVE TO EXPLAIN THAT WE ALSO IN
THESE REGULATIONS, ARE
CONSIDERING GOING, THAT, THAT
WELL, LET ME STEP BACK IN A
TRADITIONAL SECRET BALLOT
ELECTION, THERE'S SORT OF A
NOTICE THAT GOES OUT THAT'S
POSTED AT THE AT THE FARM THAT
SAYS THERE'S GOING TO BE AN
ELECTION. AND HERE'S WHERE YOU
CALL FOR INFORMATION. AND,
HERE'S WHAT HERE'S WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN. THAT WHAT WE'RE
CONSIDERING NOW IS A PROPOSAL TO
THAT'S COME FROM OUR STAFF THAT
WOULD, WHEN THOSE CARDS ARE
TURNED IN, WHICH IS THE FIRST
OFFICIAL ACT THAT HAPPENS,
THEY'RE TURNED INTO OUR BOARD,
THAT OUR BOARD WOULD THEN POST A
NOTICE AND GO TO THE, TO THE
FARM AND EXPLAIN OAN WHAT THE
PROCESS WILL BE GOING FORWARD TO
THE WORKERS. NOW, WE CAN'T GO
BEFORE THAT BECAUSE WE DON'T
KNOW THAT ANYTHING HAS HAPPENED
NECESSARILY. THE CARDS ARE BEING
COLLECTED BY A UNION AND THEN
WHEN THEY ARE SUBMITTED TO US,
THERE'S AN OFFICIAL ACT.
THEREFORE, WE CAN RESPOND
OFFICIALLY AND THAT,
COMMUNICATION SESSION WILL
INCLUDE SORT OF A QUESTION AND
ANSWER PERIOD. THANK YOU, AND
IT'S IMPORTANT. AND I JUST WANT
TO SAY ONE MORE THING. IT'S
IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE NEED TO
MAKE IT CLEAR TO EVERYBODY THAT
THIS IS ABOUT FREE CHOICE FOR
WORKERS. THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO
FORM AND JOIN UNIONS. THEY HAVE
A RIGHT TO REFRAIN FROM FORMING
AND JOINING UNIONS. AND NEITHER
SIDE CAN EXERT UNDUE PRESSURE ON
THEM TO REJECT OR SUPPORT A
UNION. IT'S GOT TO BE FREE
CHOICE. ABSOLUTELY. I AGREE,
UNDER THIS NEW LAW, AB 113, THE
UNIONS, YOU KNOW, THEY GO OUT,
THEY SET UP A TABLE, WE'VE, I'VE
HAVE PHOTOGRAPHS. WE HAVE ALL
THIS STUFF, RIGHT? THAT WHERE
YOU GO OUT AND THE NAME OF EVERY
EMPLOYEE IS ALREADY FILLED OUT.
AND WHEN THE PERSON COMES OUT TO
THE TABLE, THEY JUST SAY, SIGN
THIS. AND THE MÀ I'M TRYING TO
GET AT IS THESE FARM WORKERS
WHERE I REPRESENT THE MOST LARGE
NUMBER OF FARM WORKERS IN THE
ENTIRE STATE. THEY'RE NOT
UNDERSTANDING THAT IT'S THEY'RE
JOINING AT THAT MOMENT. SO I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT THE EDUCATION
PIECE, WHICH I WOULD LIKE TO
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU ON. AND THEN
I ALSO WANT TO KNOW THAT WHEN
THAT TABLE YOU DESCRIBED GOES UP
AND THE UNIONS OUT THERE AND
THEY'VE GOT, YOU KNOW, SHANNON
GROVE, DA DA DA DA DA WORKS AT
THIS THING AT THE HIGH PEAK. AND
I WALK UP ON THE JOB SITE TO
PULL, YOU KNOW, I WALK UP ON THE
JOB SITE, THE LAW SAYS THAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO CLEARLY
EXPRESS TO THE EMPLOYEE, HEY,
ONCE YOU SIGN THIS, YOU ARE
JOINING A UNION. ARE YOU GUYS
MAKING SURE THAT THAT HAPPENS OR
IS THAT NOT UNDER YOUR PURVIEW?
WELL IT WOULD BE UNDER OUR
PURVIEW TO EDUCATE PEOPLE ABOUT
THE PROCESS. YES, AND WE CAN
REQUIRE THE UNION TO COMMUNICATE
WHAT THE MEANING OF THE CARD IS.
ONE THING I WOULD CORRECT IS
THIS IS NOT HAPPENING AT THE
EMPLOYER'S PLACE OF EMPLOYMENT.
THE UNION HAS TO FIND THOSE
WORKERS WHERE THEY ARE, WHERE
THEY ARE. SO I JUST WANT TO MAKE
THAT CLEAR. BUT, THE IDEA THAT
WE HAVE IS THAT THE
AUTHORIZATION CARD,
TRADITIONALLY WHAT AN
AUTHORIZATION CARD JUST SAYS IS
I AUTHORIZE THE UNION TO
REPRESENT ME, IN MY WAGES, HOURS
AND WORKING CONDITIONS. THAT'S
NOT UNDER THIS. AND NOW IT'S
GOING TO SAY, THIS IS A BALLOT,
AND ESSENTIALLY A VOTE. IF YOU
SIGN THIS, YOU ARE VOTING FOR
THIS UNION TO REPRESENT YOU AT
THIS PLACE OF EMPLOYMENT. SO WE
HAVE TO RELY ALSO ON THE FACT
THAT THE WORKERS ARE HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT. AND IF THEY
DON'T WANT TO SIGN IT, THEY
DON'T HAVE TO. NOBODY CAN MAKE
THEM SIGN, SIGN THAT. AND
EMPLOYERS DO HAVE A RIGHT TO
HAVE TO EDUCATE. THEY HAVE A
RIGHT TO COMMUNICATE WITH THEIR
EMPLOYEES, GENERALLY SPEAKING,
ABOUT THEIR POSITION ABOUT
UNIONIZING ACTION. THEY CAN SAY,
WE THINK IT'S A GOOD IDEA. WE
THINK IT'S A BAD IDEA. THEY HAVE
TO BE CAREFUL THAT THEY DON'T
ENGAGE IN AN ACT OF INTIMIDATION
IN WHICH THEY SAY THINGS LIKE,
YOU KNOW, IF YOU SIGN, IF YOU
SIGN THAT CARD, I DON'T THINK
YOUR FUTURE EMPLOYMENT IS GOING
TO LOOK VERY GOOD HERE. THAT
WOULD BE ILLEGAL. BUT THEY CAN
THEY CAN RUN A GENERALIZED
INFORMATION CAMPAIGN, ONGOING,
HOWEVER THEY WANT TO DO IT, TO
SAY THIS IS OUR POSITION ABOUT
UNIONIZATION OR UNIONIZATION IN
GENERAL. WE DON'T THINK YOU NEED
IT. WE THINK WE'RE A GREAT
EMPLOYER. AND, YOU KNOW, YOU
DON'T NEED THAT OR WHATEVER YOU
WANT TO SAY. THEY HAVE TO TELL
THE TRUTH. EVERYBODY'S SUPPOSED
TO TELL THE TRUTH, AND IN THESE
CAMPAIGNS, SOMETIMES IN THE
INTENSITY OF THE MOMENT, PEOPLE
TRYING TO CONVINCE PEOPLE TO DO
THINGS CAN BE A LITTLE BIT OVER
OVERBEAR THING. SO THANK YOU,
MADAM VICE CHAIR, IF IT'S ALL
RIGHT ON THIS SPECIFIC ISSUE,
SENATOR JONES, I THINK YOU HAD A
CLARIFYING, CLARIFYING QUESTION.
YEAH. PLEASE, IF THAT'S ALL
RIGHT, VICE CHAIR. PLEASE, SIR.
SO ON THE ON THE CARDS
SPECIFICALLY, I UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING. IF THEY SIGN IT,
THAT'S A YES VOTE. BUT IF THEY
DON'T SIGN IT, IS THAT
AUTOMATIC? DOES THE CARD GET
TURNED IN AS A NO VOTE? NO. IT
DOESN'T GET TURNED IN AT ALL.
BUT THEIR VOTE. BUT THEY DON'T.
IT IT'S NOT COUNTED TOWARDS THE
50% MAJORITY. THERE YOU HAVE TO
GET 50% OF THE ELIGIBLE
EMPLOYEES. SO EVERYBODY WHO
DOESN'T SIGN A CARD IS A NO
VOTE. SO THE VOTE POOL IS SET AT
WHATEVER NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES
THAT IS AT THAT POINT IN TIME.
IF IT'S 120 EMPLOYEES OR 1200
EMPLOYEES, THAT NUMBER IS SET
AND THE UNION HAS TO GET A
MAJORITY OF WHATEVER THAT NUMBER
IS OF THE BARGAINING UNIT, IT'S
NOT A MAJORITY OF THOSE LIKE
PRESENT AND VOTING. IT'S NOT
THAT KIND OF A SYSTEM. IT'S A
MAJORITY, OUTRIGHT MAJORITY OF
EVERYBODY WHO'S ELIGIBLE ON THE
VOTE ROLL AT THAT POINT IN TIME.
CORRECT. OKAY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK TO MADAM VICE CHAIR. THANK
YOU. SO, YOU KNOW, I EXPRESSED
SOME OF MY CONCERNS THAT I HAD
YESTERDAY WITH YOU ABOUT
FARMWORKERS COMING TO MY OFFICE
AND SAYING THAT THEY WERE, YOU
KNOW, IF YOU DON'T SIGN THIS,
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO WORK
TOMORROW, AND THERE AND OVER THE
COURSE OF HISTORY, ESPECIALLY
WITH THE WIND FARM WORKER
MOVEMENT AND, YOU KNOW,
DECERTIFYING THAT ELECTION AND
WILL NOT WILL DECERTIFYING THE
ELECTION. 9010 I THINK THE FARM
WORKERS DIDN'T WANT IT, AND IT
WENT THROUGH THIS LEGISLATIVE
BODY AND THE FARM WORKERS WERE I
DON'T WANT TO SAY, ATTACKED BY
LEGISLATION, BUT THEY, YOU KNOW,
LEGISLATION WAS ADVERSARIAL
TOWARD THE FARM WORKERS AND ALL
THIS WHOLE PROCESS THAT GOES ON,
AND THE FARM WORKERS CLEARLY
SPOKE AFTER A DECISION, EVEN
AFTER THEY HAD THE SECOND OR
THIRD ROUND OF BALLOTS COUNTED
OR NOT COUNTED, THEY TAKEN, THEY
LOCKED THEM UP FOR FIVE YEARS.
THEY HAD TO GET A SUPREME COURT
DECISION TO UNLOCK THE BALLOTS,
SO ON AND SO FORTH, IS THERE
ANYTHING THAT ALRP IS DOING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE UNION AND THE
EMPLOYER, BUT THE UNION IS THE
ONE THAT'S GATHERING THESE CARDS
THAT ARE ACTUAL VOTES NOW IS
OPERATING IN GOOD FAITH AND
MAKING SURE THAT THE EMPLOYEE
UNDERSTANDS THAT THIS IS NOT A
SIGNATURE TO HAVE AN ELECTION.
THIS IS THE ELECTION. AND, ARE
THEY CLEARLY EXPRESSING THAT
THEY'RE THE UNION THAT'S GOING
TO REPRESENT THEM? THERE'S THREE
REQUIREMENTS UNDER THAT LAW. IS
THE ALRB HAVE REGULATORY
PROCESSES OR SOMETHING IN PLACE
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
COMPLYING WITH WHAT THE LAW
SAYS? YES BECAUSE THE FIRST OF
ALL, THE PARTIES CAN OBJECT, ACT
AND GET A HEARING AFTER, AFTER.
BUT THAT CAN UNDO THE
CERTIFICATION. IF THERE'S A
CERTIFICATION. SO IT'S NOT LIKE,
YOU KNOW, ONCE YOU TURN IN THE
CARDS, THERE'S NOTHING MORE THAT
CAN HAPPEN. AND IT'S A LEGAL
PROCESS THAT IS A LEGAL PROCESS.
SO THEY HAVE TO HAVE AN ATTORNEY
AND EVERYTHING ELSE. NOT
NECESSARILY THEY DON'T HAVE TO,
BUT THEY OFTEN DO, AND, AND
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S THE CAMPAIGN
ITSELF AND PEOPLE CAN FILE
UNFAIR LABOR PRACTICE CHARGES.
AND WE HAVE THREE OF THESE CASES
UNDER THIS NEW LAW PENDING. NOW,
I CAN'T TALK ABOUT THEM
INDIVIDUALLY. TÊ. AND NONE OF
WHAT I'M SAYING HERE IS ABOUT
ANY INDIVIDUAL CASE. BUT THE
PARTIES CAN FIRE FILE UNFAIR
LABOR PRACTICE CHARGES.
EMPLOYERS CAN FILE THEM AGAINST
UNIONS, AND UNIONS CAN FILE THEM
AGAINST EMPLOYERS, AND
INDIVIDUAL WORKERS CAN FILE THEM
AGAINST ANYBODY ELSE. THEY WANT
TO FILE THEM EITHER SIDE AND
THOSE ALSO ARE A WAY OF DEALING
WITH ACTS OF INTIMIDATION,
MISREPRESENTATION, AN ANYTHING
LIKE IF SOMETHING HAPPENED ALONG
WHAT YOU SAID THAT WOULD IF IT
WAS TRUE, WOULD, COULD
INVALIDATE THE VOTE THAT WOULD
BE UNLAWFUL. THANK YOU SIR,
THANK YOU. THAT'S WHAT I NEEDED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU,
MADAM VICE CHAIR. NO, THANK YOU
SO MUCH. WE'RE GOING TO CHECK IN
WITH SENATOR EGGMAN, PLEASE.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. NICE TO
SEE YOU, MR. BRAD, I WANTED TO
ASK JUST SOME ABOUT YOUR ABILITY
TO OUTREACH TO FARM WORKERS. AS
I. IT'S 100 DEGREES OUTSIDE
RIGHT NOW, SO WE KNOW THERE'S NO
FARMERS WHO SHOULD BE WORKING
BECAUSE OF HEAT ISSUES. AND I
KNOW YOUR YOUR ORGANIZATION HAS
HAS CONTRACTED. SO TELL ME ABOUT
REACHING OUT TO AGRICULTURE
COMMUNITIES, MAKING SURE PEOPLE
KNOW ABOUT THEIR RIGHTS,
ESPECIALLY WITH WITH THIS HEAT
CHILD LABOR LAWS AND THEN EVEN
THE WAGE THEFT. SO, WE'RE A
RELATIVELY SMALL AGENCY LIKE 50,
BUT WE HAVE INCREASED THANKS TO
INCREASED IN SIZE IN THIS AREA.
WE'VE HIRED A EXPANDED OUR
OUTREACH AND HAVE SPECIFIC
OUTREACH PERSONNEL WHO GO OUT
THERE. THEY NOT WE ARE NOT ONLY
HAVE PEOPLE WHO SPEAK SPANISH,
BUT WHO SPEAK THE INCREASINGLY
WE I MEAN THIS IS A NUMEROUS
PART OF THE FARM WORKER
POPULATION. OAN DOESN'T SPEAK
SPANISH. THEY SPEAK INDIGENOUS
LANGUAGES, AND SO WE HAVE PEOPLE
WHO SPEAK INDIGENOUS LANGUAGES.
AND THERE ARE HUGE, BIG CULTURAL
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE TWO, AND
WE GO OUT THERE AND WE, WE
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT
DIRECTLY THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
PEOPLE, BUT WE DON'T LIKE TO SEE
THIS AS AN OVERLY BUREAUCRATIC
THING. IF WE SEE EVIDENCE OF,
SLAVERY AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING IN
THE LABOR MARKET, IF WE SEE,
EVIDENCE OF HEALTH AND SAFETY,
WE WILL CONTACT LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IF IT WAS SOMETHING LIKE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING, WE WILL CONTACT, WE
WILL CONTACT CAL OSHA IF IT'S A
HEALTH AND SAFETY ISSUE. I MEAN,
WE DON'T WE DON'T CONSIDER IT
OUR JOB TO NOT TO PUT BLINDERS
ON AND NOT DEAL WITH THE REALITY
AS PEOPLE, AS WE SEE IT, WE'RE
OUT THERE ALL THE TIME. THE
BOARD ITSELF, THAT IS, THE FIVE
BOARD MEMBERS, WE DON'T REALLY
ADMINISTER THAT PART. THAT'S
DONE THROUGH THE GENERAL COUNSEL
. AND AS YOU KNOW, IN OUR
AGENCY, IT'S BIFURCATE AND THE
GENERAL COUNSEL'S OFFICE, IS
SORT OF A SEPARATE SOURCE OF
INDEPENDENT POWER. WE DON'T WE
SORT OF CO-MANAGE THE, THE, THE,
THE SYSTEM, AND BECAUSE THEY ARE
A LITIGANT BEFORE US, SO WE HAVE
TO BE WE HAVE A KIND OF WHAT
THEY CALL THE FIREWALL, WHICH IS
NOT JUST RHETORICAL. THERE'S
ACTUALLY A WALL LITERALLY IN OUR
OFFICE BETWEEN US, AND WE DON'T
GO BARGING THROUGH THEIR VERY
OFTEN. AND, SO, THE ANSWER IS
YES. WE HAVE INCREASED THAT
STAFF, EVEN THOUGH WE ARE A
SMALL STAFF AND WE'RE OUT THERE
ALL THE TIME AT COMMUNITY
EVENTS. ON IN MEDIA AND, AND
TRYING TO SORT OF GET THE WORD
OUT OF WHAT, WHAT PEOPLE'S
RIGHTS ARE, WHERE THEY GO TO
ANSWER THEIR QUESTIONS. WHERE DO
THEY GO TO ANSWER THEIR
QUESTIONS, WHETHER THEY'RE
QUESTIONS THAT BELONG TO US OR
BELONG TO SOMEBODY ELSE. SO AND
YOU WOULD SEE WORKPLACE VIOLENCE
FALLING UNDER THAT SAME PURVIEW.
ABSOLUTELY. I MEAN, IF WE SEE IF
WE SEE CRIMINAL CONDUCT, IT'S
OUR OBLIGATION TO TALK IT TO
ESSENTIALLY CALL THE POLICE. AND
WHETHER IT'S THE FBI OR, YOU
KNOW, THE LOCAL POLICE, I GUESS
WE'RE WORKING. I JUST HAD TO GO
SIT THROUGH A WORKPLACE
VIOLENCE, SEMINAR YESTERDAY. AND
WE KNOW WORKPLACE VIOLENCE IS
INCREASING, ESPECIALLY WITH GUNS
. AND THAT IN HALF MOON BAY TWO
YEARS AGO. YES THERE WAS A MASS
SHOOTING. RIGHT. SO THOSE KINDS
OF THINGS ARE IS THERE ANY
TRAINING OR IS THAT THROUGH CAL
OSHA, IS THERE ANY OUTREACH OR
TRAINING PROVIDED? THERE IS,
WELL, THERE IS THROUGH CAL OSHA
FOR SURE, SPECIFICALLY TO ON
WORKPLACE VIOLENCE AS SUCH,
BECAUSE WORKPLACE VIOLENCE
OBVIOUSLY DOESN'T NECESSARILY
COME FROM YOUR COWORKERS, AS
HAPPENED IN HALF MOON BAY. IT
COULD BE JUST A INSANE MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC. YOU KNOW, MOST OFTEN
A COWORKER. TURNS OUT IT IS. BUT
IT DOESN'T ONLY HAPPEN THAT WAY.
SO THAT YOU NEED GENERALIZED
TRAINING, WHICH INVOLVES
PROTECTING PEOPLE ON THE JOB.
OH, GOD. AND, BUT, AND THE
EMPLOYERS NEED THAT TRAINING AS
WELL. THAT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT'S JUST ABOUT WORKERS.
EVERYBODY NEEDS TO KNOW WHAT TO
DO. SO, BUT WE WE'RE NOT ON
THAT. WE'RE SORT OF A SECOND
LINE DISCUSSION. LIKE, SOMETIMES
PEOPLE WILL COME UP TO US AND
SAY, YOU KNOW, THEY DON'T KNOW
THE WORKERS AREN'T SO
SOPHISTICATED THAT THEY KNOW,
OH, YOU GUYS DO THE LABOR
RELATIONS STUFF, BUT YOU DON'T
DO THE OTHER STUFF. SO THEY'LL
SAY, YOU KNOW, HEY, WE HAVE THIS
PROBLEM WHERE WE'RE WORKING, YOU
KNOW, WHAT DO WE DO? AND WE'LL
WE'LL TRY TO FOLLOW UP AND GET
THEM TO THE RIGHT PLACE. THANK
YOU. OKAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
PLEASE, SIR. LAIRD THANK YOU. I
THANK MY COLLEAGUES. COVERED A
LOT OF GROUND. THE ONE THING I
THOUGHT I'D ASK ABOUT IS IN YOUR
PAPERS OR INTERVIEWS. YOU TALKED
ABOUT YOUR PREVIOUS TERM AND ALL
THE THINGS THAT YOU HAD DONE TO
AFFECT THE PROBLEM WAS THE
BACKLOG, THE TIME SOME OF THE
PROCESSING. TALK ABOUT WHAT YOU
FEEL LIKE HAVE BEEN SOME OF THE
SUCCESSES OUT OF YOUR YOUR TERM.
I THINK, YOU KNOW, OUR BOARD HAS
WORKED VERY HARD WITH OUR
GENERAL COUNSEL'S OFFICE TO TRY
TO SPEED UP THE PROCESS. BEFORE
THE CASES EVEN GET TO THE BOARD,
OBVIOUSLY, SOMEONE FILES A
CHARGE, THERE'S AN
INVESTIGATION, AND THEN OUR
GENERAL COUNSEL ISSUES A
COMPLAINT THAT PERIOD SHOULD BE
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENS QUICKLY,
BECAUSE THESE ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
SYSTEMS WERE INTENDED TO PROVIDE
QUICK JUSTICE, NOT SLOW JUSTICE.
IT ISN'T. THAT'S WHY IT'S NOT
THE COURTS, AND SO WE RECOGNIZE
THAT AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE,
BECAUSE IT'S ONLY FAIR TO THE
WORKERS OR WHOEVER FILES THE
CHARGE, WHICH IS MOSTLY WORKERS,
BUT ALSO TO THE EMPLOYERS,
BECAUSE THERE'S THIS THING
HANGING OVER THEM FOR A YEAR AND
A HALF BEFORE THEY EVEN KNOW
WHETHER THERE'S A COMPLAINT
THAT'S GOING TO BE ISSUED OR
NOT. THAT'S JUST TOO LONG TO
WAIT. SO WE'VE WORKED ON, ON
SPEEDING THAT PROCESS UP, AND
WE'VE BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN
SPEEDING THAT PROCESS UP. AND I
THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE
JUSTICE DELAYED IS JUSTICE
DENIED. AND AND YOU DON'T WANT
TO BE FOUR YEARS DOWN THE LINE
WHEN YOU GET YOUR BACK PAY
AWARD. RIGHT. IT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE. SO, AND THEN THE OTHER
THING WE'VE DONE IS WE'VE TRIED
TO RATIONALIZE AND REDO OUR
REGULATIONS. I KNOW THIS IS
BORING, BUT THESE SYSTEMS NEED
TO WORK THE GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO
WORK FOR PEOPLE. IT NEEDS TO BE
FUNCTIONAL, NOT JUST WRITE WHAT
THE LAW IS, YOU KNOW, BUT SO
THAT PEOPLE KNOW HOW TO USE IT
AND THEY CAN ACCESS JUSTICE AND
THEY CAN DO IT WITHOUT IT BEING
SO COMPLICATED THAT IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE TO FIGURE OUT. AND SO
WE'VE WORKED A LOT ON THAT, I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO US ISSUING
THIS REGULATORY PACKAGE ON
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB 113 SO THAT
THE THAT WE HAVE THAT PROCESS
STRAIGHTENED OUT AND STREAMLINED
AND AS EFFICIENT AS POSSIBLE.
AND WE'VE MADE IT AS MUCH OF A
STAKEHOLDER FOR HEAVY PROCESS AS
WE COULD POSSIBLY MAKE IT. WE I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
TALK TO THE PEOPLE THAT DO THIS
KIND OF WORK, BECAUSE THERE'S
GOOD IDEAS, THERE'S BAD IDEAS,
AND FRANKLY, THERE'S DUMB IDEAS.
AND, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE CAN LIKE
OR DISLIKE IT, BUT YOU DON'T
WANT IT TO BE DUMB. YOU WANT IT
TO WORK. AND THAT'S WHAT WE TRY
TO DO, THAT'S A COLLOQUY THAT
SHOULD BE REPEATED IN OTHER
COMMITTEES. I MAY HAVE IN MY
CAREER. AND YOU GOT CONFIRMED
ANYWAY, RIGHT? YEAH. OKAY THANK
YOU. THAT WAS REALLY HELPFUL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, SIR. ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS, COMMENTS,
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? ALL RIGHT.
HEARING SEEING NONE. WHAT WE'D
LIKE TO DO IS OPEN IT UP FOR
THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF MR.
BROD, IF YOU CAN, PLEASE COME
FORWARD FIRST, LAST NAME
ORGANIZATION. AND WE'RE GOING TO
ASK FOLKS TO KEEP IT TO 30S,
PLEASE. I WONDER WHAT POSITION
THIS GUY'S GONE. WELL, IN MY
PERSONAL CAPACITY OR MY
PROFESSIONAL CAPACITY. MATT
BROD, HERE, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS COUNCIL, WE'RE, PROUD TO
SUPPORT BARRY, WHO'S ALSO MY
FATHER. AND, WE WOULD LOVE TO
SEE HIM. CONFIRMED. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MISS PRIDE.
HEY. GOOD AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR
MEMBER SARA FLOCKS, CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION, I WILL SAY I
HAD THE GREAT PRIVILEGE OF
STARTING MY CAREER WORKING
ALONGSIDE BARRY. AND LEARNING
FROM HIM. AND I THINK HIS
TESTIMONY SUMS UP WHY HE IS SUCH
A GREAT APPOINTEE. HE HAS A DEEP
UNDERSTANDING AND RESPECT FOR
THE LAW AND WHERE IT COMES FROM,
AND THE FACT THAT PEOPLE FOUGHT
FOR IT TO ADDRESS PROBLEMS, TO
STOP VIOLENCE IN THE FIELDS.
LIKE HE SAID ABOUT THE ALRA AND
HE IS A DEEP RESPECT AND
UNDERSTANDING OF THE IMPORTANCE
OF THE LAW AS SOMETHING THAT
IMPACTS PEOPLE'S LIVES. WE HAVE
TO IMPLEMENT IT. IT HAS TO BE
IMPLEMENTED EFFECTIVELY,
QUICKLY, SO THAT PEOPLE ARE ABLE
TO GET JUSTICE. AND I THINK HE
WILL BE A GREAT APPOINTEE, EVEN
THOUGH WE MISS HIM VERY MUCH,
AND WE'RE FULLY, FULLY SUPPORT
HIS REAPPOINTMENT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU. IS
THAT BRIAN? MR. PRO TEM AND
SENATORS JASON. BRIAN, ON BEHALF
OF WESTERN UNITED DAIRIES, THE
DAIRY FARMING FAMILIES OF
CALIFORNIA ARE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT BARRY BRODD HERE TODAY
FOR APPOINTMENT. WE FIND HIM TO
BE A THOUGHTFUL AND TRUSTED
MEMBER OF THE BOARD. WE'RE
PLEASED TO SEE HIM BEING
REAPPOINTED TODAY AND PROUD TO
SUPPORT HIM. THANK YOU. IT'S
GOOD TO SEE YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WE'D LIKE TO ME TO DO A
FINAL CALL FOR THOSE WHO MAY BE
IN SUPPORT. IF YOU COULD PLEASE
STEP FORWARD AT THIS TIME
HEARING, SEEING NO ONE RISE, WE
ARE NOW GOING TO ASK THOSE WHO
MAY BE OPPOSED. IF YOU COULD
PLEASE STEP FORWARD AT THIS TIME
LOOKING FOR THOSE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSED. FIRST AND LAST NAME AN
ORGANIZATION SEEING NO ONE RISE.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE TO BE ABLE TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS. WE'LL ALSO LOOK FOR A
MOTION. I WOULD MOVE THE
CONFIRMATION TO THAT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR. SENATOR JONES. I JUST
WANTED TO TELL A QUICK PERSONAL
STORY AND THEN KIND OF RELAY MY
POSITION ON THE ON THE
APPOINTMENT, WHEN I FIRST GOT
ELECTED IN 2010, MR. BROD WAS
ONE OF THE VERY FIRST,
SACRAMENTO PROFESSIONALS TO COME
TO MY OFFICE AND TALK ABOUT HIS
ADVOCACY FOR HIS ORGANIZATION
WITHOUT KNOWING AT THE TIME THAT
ONE OR MAYBE TWO OF MY KIDS WERE
ACTUALLY MEMBERS OF THE
TEAMSTERS AT THAT TIME. AND SO
WE HAVE HAD A GREAT CONVERSATION
SINCE THEN, AND, AND A POSITIVE
WORKING RELATIONSHIP,
UNFORTUNATELY, I HAVEN'T SEEN
YOU AS MUCH RECENTLY. SO, BUT I
DO ENJOY, SEEING YOU AND I DO
AND OBVIOUSLY, WORKING WITH
MATTHEW, HE'S DOING A GOOD JOB
AS WELL. REGARDING THE
APPOINTMENT. PRECISELY. THERE
ARE SOME CONCERNS REGARDING THE
REGULATIONS THAT THE BOARD IS,
PROPAGATING RIGHT NOW. I KNOW
THAT THERE'S A LAWSUIT, IN
REACTION TO SOME OF THAT. SO,
I'M GOING TO ABSTAIN FROM THE
FROM THE APPOINTMENT VOTE TODAY,
BUT, HOPE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
ON. I KNOW, AND I KNOW WE WILL.
I DON'T EVEN NEED TO SAY THAT,
OUR PROFESSIONAL RELATIONSHIP
WILL CONTINUE, AND HOPEFULLY
WE'LL BE ABLE TO WORK THROUGH
SOME OF THESE ISSUES AND GET
THEM IRONED OUT. SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MR. JONES. ALL RIGHT. WE DO HAVE
A MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY SENATOR
EGGMAN. ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE PRIOR TO
GOING TO A VOTE HEARING, SEEING
NONE. MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL? MCGUIRE.
AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE. GROVE. GROVE.
NOT VOTING. EGGMAN EGGMAN. AYE.
JONES. JONES. NOT VOTING. LAIRD.
LAIRD. AYE. 3 TO 0. THAT IS A30
VOTE. THAT MOTION PASSES.
CONGRATULATIONS. THANK YOU. NEXT
UP IS SENATE FLOOR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU.
LIKEWISE. VERY GRATEFUL. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN. WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO DO IS WE'RE GOING TO HAVE,
ADD ON ITEM ONE. BE THE VICE
CHAIR. ON TO THE VOTE, SO WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO DO IS WE'RE GOING
TO OPEN IT UP. ITEM ONE B, THIS
IS FOR, DIRECTOR PATENT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS.
MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS GROVE.
GROVE. AYE. FIVE. THAT'S FIVE
ZERO BIPARTISAN VOTE. THAT
MOTION PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO
CLOSE THE ROLL ON THAT. ALL
RIGHT, LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE MOVING
INTO THE CLOSED SESSION. THE
EXECUTIVE SESSION, PART OF
TODAY'S RULES COMMITTEE AGENDA.
WE'RE GOING TO RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THOSE WHO ARE IN THE
ROOM IF YOU COULD PLEASE VACATE
AND THEN WE'LL TAKE UP OUR
EXECUTIVE SESSION. WE'LL START
EXECUTIVE SESSION IN 30S.